this is Joo podcast number 414 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Ekko good
evening one day A bunch of us were
playing we didn't have slides or monkey
bars so we reverted to basic boy stuff
we found rocks and threw them at things
of course we eventually started throwing
them at each other in the beginning we
just threw them at each other's feet but
boys being boys we were hardwired for
Warfare before along this kid who had
already had a hard on for me being the
smallest and weakest Target available
was gleefully throwing rocks at my face
as hard as he could he was a little
serial killer in the making he
legitimately got off on watching me be
terrified I remember being on my hands
and knees asking him to stop as he
searched for another rock to throw the
pretense of any sort of game was by then
gone he wasn't even throwing them at me
as much as he was just dropping them on
my head at Point Blank
Range I had some sort of a realization
that this kid would not stop he would
just keep doing this forever if I
survived today he wouldn't just be there
tomorrow and the next day or he would
just be there tomorrow and the next day
it wasn't
fair
suddenly I was standing up with a rock
in my hand a big one and not a smooth
Rock like you find on a river in the
country this was a jagged lump of
wrecked New Jersey concrete the kind of
rock that scraped up your hand just by
picking it
up as the bully closed within arms
distance I threw a ma Haymaker at him as
hard as I could the punch alone might
have rattled him it hit him directly on
the ear but with the rock of New Jersey
Justice in my hand it did quite a bit
more than that his ear
exploded a combination of the cartilage
being burst by the blunt force of The
Rock and the skin being torn open by its
Jagged edges instead of swelling his ear
up all the fluid the body sent to the
ear to protect it gushed
out everyone froze for a few seconds
just to
register well except for my bully he
regressed from whatever age he was back
to a toddler screaming bloody murder he
crumpled to the ground and curled up in
a pitiful little ball of dirt and
blood that's when he probably was that's
what he probably was anyways just a
frustrated toddler at
heart I'll never forget the other kids
staring down at this Bully Now crumpled
on the sand holding his
ear he had lost 100% of his power he
could come back the next day and try and
hurt every single one of us but he would
never be the same once you've seen a
person shrunk drunken into the fetal
position that's all you'll ever see when
you look at them his hand was caked with
blood and dirt and more blood was
steadily dripping out making more of a
Mess by the
second they looked from him up at me a
paradigm shift occurred for everyone in
that sand pit don't mess with Tom
anymore and that right there is nexer
from a book called How You bear it
Triumph and resilience in life the book
is by Tom de blast and Tom is a
Jiu-Jitsu competitor he's a ghe and noi
Champion he's also an MMA fighter with
fights in ring of combat Bellator and
the
UFC he's also a Jiu-Jitsu and submission
grappling coach he's a teacher with over
50 Affiliated Jiu-Jitsu schools on five
different continents he also runs a
charity which is called buddies over
bullies which is very fitting and that
works with communities and individuals
to stop bullying and
abuse and Tom has had a hard journey
himself through life including bullying
and
abuse but he was able to stop that cycle
for himself and his family and now he is
helping others to do the same and it's
an honor to have Tom here with us
tonight to share his experiences and
Lessons Learned Tom thanks for joining
us man the honor is mine thank you so
much for having me here guys I really
appreciate it yeah it's pretty wild as I
was reading reading your book um there's
a lot of a lot of adjacent scenarios
going on with ADCC with trials then the
time frame that you were competing in
and uh I know I think the first time I
ever met you I don't you may or may not
remember this but I think I was
backstage I was cornering probably Dean
liser and I think you were cornering uh
Gary yes sir at metamoris at metamoris
yeah yeah that's the first time I I
might have met you before that but
that's like the first time I remember
but uh we were also well we'll get to it
but we were also in Spain together at
ADCC yes I was over there corner and de
you were over there competing so there's
going to be some some interesting
crossover of the Jiu-Jitsu world yes yes
yes yeah I I remember that I remember I
I was I was taken back by how kind you
are not that I didn't expect you to be
kind but when we hear about you know
military people I thought the handshake
would try to break my hand and you were
just a really gentle nice guy you know
and I was like wow this guy's a really
good guy man you know so it was cool to
like we're all sitting back there and
for whatever reason I mean we must have
been like either red corner or blue
corner or something like that but
also I mean basically we're Americans M
you know what I mean so you're Americans
and it's kind of like oh what are you
guys doing and I remember we're looking
at some you know looking at some foot
locks look like some heel hooks just
kind of uh brainstorming and stuff like
that yeah Dean was actually showing Gary
something I believe right yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember it's been an interesting
uh to watch cuz I really have had an
Insider view on Dean since the beginning
you know when he when he went and won in
2003 and Brazil the absolute and he heel
hooked
kako and people have never seen that
before Dean had been doing that move to
me for like 3 years I was like bro this
is of course he's going to get that but
uh the position now called 5050 and the
fact that you say that he he'll hooked
kako and a lot of my listeners don't
have no idea what you're talking about
to me is madness right like you'll say
names like Dean lisst or Ricardo Arona
and who's Arona who's Arona you know
what I mean uh yeah man Dean is such an
OG truly like he did The Impossible it's
quite incredible and then he came back
and he did it again you know
unbelievable it's pretty cool that
donaher gives him like the props that he
gives to Dean cuz you know he he Dean is
not a marketer right no Dean is not a
guy that is going to go out there and be
like Oh and and he he is he he's the
best teacher I've ever worked with I
mean you know I mean obviously I'm
biased towards him because he's my
friend and he and I've been training
with him for a long time but he ALS Al
is he he's not a guy that has the the
the mindset to like make a video
compilation or to name like Eddie Bravo
named moves that doesn't seem like a big
deal but it's kind of a big deal it's
kind of mar himself it's like a it's
like a it's something to do to make
people understand that this is your
stuff and when people start talking
about rubber guard like there's other
people that did that but Eddie Bravo
gave that thing a name and like this is
what it is the one who and it's like
that's good for him and he did awesome
with it uh but Dean doesn't have that
mind and and so it's very cool that Don
her is cool enough to just be like yeah
I got this idea for this stuff from this
guy Dean Lis 100% you know Dean is he's
a simple guy that's a genius on the mats
and he doesn't care about the business
aspect of things and one thing that I
always like I tell my athletes like uh
you know it worked for Dean is Dean but
the fact is you know 99% of competitors
will never accomplish what Dean has
that's just what it is uh and I tell my
athletes I said listen you have to be
more nowadays you have to be more than a
competitor you have to learn the social
aspect of things because there's so much
behind everything you know like you said
Eddie named these these moves so now
people who don't know Jitsu they come in
oh Eddie Eddie Bravo invented that well
Eddie's fantastic but did Eddie really
invent every single thing you know you
know and there's a lot of the stuff that
that I don't know all the 10th planet
names you know what I mean like well
yeah like the Twister is a good example
right cuz the Twister is a guillotine in
wrestling but yes they call it the
Twister and you can't call it the
guillotine because we have the
guillotine and Jiu-Jitsu but that's a
classic thing and so this is something
he took from Eddie Bravo took it from
wrestling and he of course turned it
into a six submission he made it his own
and made it his own and so yeah it's you
know everyone there there's just some
iconic people for sure uh that have gone
out there but and and then Don and her
taking the whole thing and just like
turning it into
what it is today where it's a huge part
of the game and it wasn't it wasn't a
huge part of the game before I mean it
was not part of the game before it
really was 100% it was just like Dean
and so anyways there we go we already
went little tangental situation we start
talking about that
Jiu-Jitsu uh but let's get into your
life a little bit because your story
definitely I think is going to resonate
with a lot of people um I want to read a
little chunk from your book here we get
to the kind of with your
background my father began drinking when
he was 12 and his father was a
functioning alcoholic as well they lived
in an area when an era when alcoholism
was was barely acknowledged there were a
few books fewer there were few books
fewer treatment centers and no hotlines
alcohol was socially accepted socially
accepted way to cope I got hints over
the years that my father let's just say
he had plenty of things to cope with you
might think a man like this wouldn't
tolerate weakness in a son but again he
wasn't a typical alcoholic when I would
come home crying because the
neighborhood kids picked on me a sober
dad would always was always there to
comfort me I was free to cry around him
he would do what every Dad should do get
on one knee and wrap his arms around me
he'd tell me that it was okay ask me
what happened and do all that good dad
stuff that I try and do with my kids now
in reality I know my dad wasn't really
two people that's some thing that
children of addicts just sort of need to
believe sometimes separate the man from
the addict
my father was a good person but he was a
complex person mentally strong yet
hopelessly addicted tender with his son
but able to smash bricks not
surprisingly I had many of these same
traits from A young age my mother
Deborah was on the other side of the de
Blas coin she was then and now is the
strongest toughest woman I've ever met
in my life sometimes I think she
deserves a book more than me my
childhood wasn't always easy but it
paled in comparison to hers Deborah was
born Bor in East Orange New Jersey a
mainly black neighborhood and by mainly
I mean Deborah was the only white girl
in her High School Savvy history readers
May note that Deborah would have been in
the correct time and place for the 1967
race riots in New Jersey and she was but
that was almost a foot footnote in her
life story Deborah's mother was born and
raised in an orphanage with no family of
her own I can't blame my grandmother for
not being a stellar parent she married
an alcoholic and the two had a turbulent
marriage my mother was kidnapped when
she was five or six and wasn't reunited
with her family for years her kidnapper
was none other than her own father a
severe alcoholic himself he took not
just my mother but her infant brother as
well or he took not just my mother but
my but her infant brother as well you
might imagine that Deborah's mother
would have moved Heaven and Earth to
find her children but she never really
made a serious effort to find
them so that's kind of setting the stage
man yeah it sounds like a movie it's
quite incredible and that's just really
the tip of the iceberg you know my mom
read the book she's like oh thank God
you didn't put the whole entire story in
there and people who read it are like oh
man your life was so crazy I was like
this is the PG version man you know yeah
my mother was my grandfather was a he
was an amazing man but he was kind of
similar to my father um he was a slave
to addiction but he was a lover you know
he loved my mother with all of his heart
uh he loved me with all of his heart you
know and my grandmother was more of a a
stoic to where she didn't really show
emotion but to preface that there was
one time my grandmother was in a diner
when she was a young girl and she saw
her mother and she knew who her mother
was her mother knew who she was cuz she
gave her up a few years in and she said
mom and her mother looked at her and
said I don't know you cuz she was with
man and she just completely denied her
so my mother ended up basically raising
her brother my Uncle David who died of
cancer God bless his soul he was a he
was a very uh turbulent man as well to
say the least in and out of prison and
uh you know my mother I didn't realize
that I never realized my mother had
flaws until I was a a parent of my own
right because I basically was like a
partner to her we would come home every
day hey is daddy drunk or is he High we
would make a bet to where no we
shouldn't be betting about that and you
know it's like I was her her Ally
against him and we just always stuck
together because leaving him wasn't an
option because I don't believe she could
she wasn't financially able to but also
at the same time I didn't want her to
cuz we knew if my mother left my father
he would be dead uh when I was born the
week after my mother got a call that my
dad overdosed and died in Harlem and she
was on her way to identify the body and
my dad was walking down the street in a
hospital gown they actually said the
wrong person died my dad didn't die he
was alive but then he disappeared out of
her life and my life for like eight
months and when he came back he thought
he was gone for like 3 days you know he
had a lot of lot of
uh problems you know and my mother ended
up being she she was 10 years older or
younger than him and he met her when she
just needed some kind of stability and
you know even salt looks like sugar
right so she thought she could get that
stability in him and since she's so used
to abuse when he would mess up and be
abusive you know you just think that's
what love is through thick and thin and
uh we both got used to that abuse
because some days he would be wonderful
and some days he would be Satan and uh I
didn't know any other way besides
turbulence like and now I still struggle
with it like when things are too smooth
I I feel like they shouldn't be this way
you know you find comfort in hell and
there's just uh I've seen my father
overdose and die in front of me and get
brought back and the first time I saw
that I was like four you know and uh
it's just just a cycle of that non-stop
there's I remember one time he he was
really drunk and and he was crying and I
I was I was a little boy and I was was
trying to comfort him and I remember
that the he was sweaty cuz we didn't
have air conditioning excuse me I
remember the sweat on his chest was like
getting all over my face when I was
hugging him and he was like and he
started saying how he killed he's like I
just I killed him I killed him and at
that moment I realized like all right
you have a lot of regrets about things
you've done you know I never asked about
who he killed or what he was talking
about or perhaps he didn't kill anyone
you know uh he served but he went to uh
Panama during the Vietnam they didn't
send him out to fight and the thing is
with my dad he was a he was a good man
like he wouldn't kill a bug you know he
he was he was very gentle to animals
gentle to people uh he would give to the
homeless but when he was not sober he
was just a terrible terrible human being
and he just kept making the same mistake
over and over right to to to escape the
pain he would get drunk and high and
then only to come back back and regret
what he just did again and Escape all
over again and it became a cycle to
where I would just say dad please just I
forgive you just live for today I don't
care about yesterday but he can never do
that up until his dying day he can never
do that what what drugs was he taking
well I I only thought he did I only
thought he drank alcohol you know I
never seen my father pick up a drink he
always would do it I'd never seen it it
was never accepted but my junior year
High School I was a track and field
Runner my dad wasn't in the house and I
went to uh call my dad because you
saying I'm my grandparents and my mom
was like uh you can't call him my mom's
great at stuff like this she'll say
stuff without prefacing what really she
means so I'm like what do you mean you
can't call him she's like he overdosed
last night she didn't say don't worry
Tom he he's alive and I thought he was
dead uh he overdosed on heroin so he did
all kinds of drugs he was more of a
downer type guy but he was addicted to
heroin uh he was addicted the alcohol
pills anything my dad would drink
mouthwash if he could get it what did he
do for a living like who's paying the
bills he was a barber uh he had his own
business and lost it had his own
business and lost it uh then he had his
own business and lost it again and then
he would be in and out of rehab probably
about 50 times my mom would work at the
hospital she would work nights and then
come back and stay with me during the
day so my dad was always out of work and
my mom paid the bill B for the most part
or when he did go to work he you know he
would do his best to to pay the bills
but you know that day he overdosed that
was like a huge wakeup call I went to
school that day and uh I broke my long
jump School record that day I jumped uh
2210 22t 10 in and I was just so fired
up and I was so upset I think a part of
me wanted to do it to prove to him but
in the same sense it broke my heart that
I broke the record when he wasn't there
because I know when he came out of that
that coma that was one more thing that
my father missed that would make him go
back to the drugs once again my father
missed my own wedding the the day of the
you know when I woke up to to go to his
house uh he was in his tuck passed out
on the couch super high and um he just
didn't go to my wedding you know that's
just it's just how it was you know he
was on methadone I would take him to the
methadone clinic uh and then I found out
he was taking like 20 benad dril a day
with the methadone to prolong the
halflife of the methadone it's just
Madness with him you know man that
addiction thing is just it's it's crazy
it's brutal you know it really is and I
forgive him and I always have forgiven
him because Who Wants to Be an addict
you know but at the same time now that
I'm a father now that I'm a father when
I look at my own kids I realize how
awful at times he was as a parent
because when I was a
not a father I would look at myself as
just a man and he's a man he's flawed
I'm flawed and we're just two men
there's a song that's a beautiful song
it's a a big uh Samoan guy or Hawaiian
guy sings it uh I forget the name of but
he's incredible and it's just basically
like I don't judge you you don't judge
me we're just two men that make mistakes
right so I didn't judge him until I have
my own kids and I'm like excuse me I can
never imagine putting my children
through the things that he put me
through and allow them to see what I've
seen uh it's horrific you know and it
does a real number on you and at the
same time I I can't imagine how my mom
would allow me to be witness to this but
she didn't break the cycle right so
that's what it came down to she was also
very mental in her own right uh and I
didn't realize that till after my father
passed away but you know I'm so thankful
that he was who he was because I have a
very addicted person personality but my
addiction became
like you know Sports uh bettering myself
you know exercise I got addicted to that
at a young age and I truly was addicted
uh and if it wasn't that if I didn't
realize that that that alcoholic was
within me uh which it is I probably
could have been my father and perhaps my
kids could have witnessed all the things
that I've witnessed you know it's just
really tough man it's really
tough
yeah you you say in the book here
um around the second grade a teacher
began to remark that I wasn't like the
other kids even back in the 80s it
wasn't hard to diagnose me as depressed
my school referred me to some sort of
psychologist I'll never forget the first
and only time I met with him by the end
of our session he literally had knotted
off to fall asleep I never saw a
professional again but the depression
wasn't going away it was quite
incredible Like You Gotta Laugh I
literally I I didn't know what suicide
was as a little kid but I would uh oh
real quick if you guys hear me clearing
my throat I have something called uh
tick it's like a like a minor form of
trets like I I I twitch a lot uh I have
syberia DHD and I have tick so I always
have something that I'm doing so if you
guys on the podcast listening I
apologize for my I'm sorry uh so yeah I
just would pray to God for him to take
me to Heaven every day you know I I just
didn't want to be I don't know if
anybody listened to this saw the movie
Powder
uh it's a really good movie and this guy
was uh he was an albino and he was just
a very good boy and the world wasn't for
him you know his heart but he was like
magical though he he had powers I never
had powers unfortunately but you know I
would look
at again I was so soft as a kid like I
would never hurt anybody or anything uh
never hurt an animal I never took my
anger out on someone else I just didn't
want other people to feel the pain that
I felt and anytime other people felt
pain I would feel their pain so it's
like not only did I feel my own pain and
depression anytime I saw somebody else
that was going through something and it
could even be a sad movie I didn't know
how to compartmentalize things and all
that sadness would just way on my back
way on my back and I was just so sad I
just did not like this this world this
Earth and I I wanted to get out of here
uh I didn't know what suicide was but I
clearly I was had Suicidal Thoughts From
You Know 6 seven years old on all the
way through until my early
20s and then you go into this and this
is pretty early in the
book I was 7 years old when it happened
he was 13 He molested me just one time
in his room it's hard to understate how
unprepared an 8-year-old is for sexual
activities I had no real understanding
of sexuality certainly not the
particulars but more than that I had
limited I had a limited understanding of
emotions of any kind and I didn't even
have the words in my vocabulary to
understand or vocalize what happened
what I did have was the most damaging
thing a very simplistic understanding of
morality what happened to me was
complicated a child who was very likely
himself being abused abused another
child it's hard to say what level of
culpability or even understanding he had
of what he was doing these are the types
of things that legal systems and even
philosophers would struggle with but my
seven-year-old mind couldn't discern any
of this instead I went into emotional
Retreat one that would last well into my
adult life to this day I think of the
child who molested me he was a victim he
was in his own emotional Retreat from
someone
else but he still did it and I was never
the same in the immediate aftermath I
felt enormous guilt and shame I had read
stories about Sodom and Gomorrah from
the Bible God had destroyed entire
cities over
homosexuality a narrative emerged in my
mind about what we had done not about
what he had done to me molestation was
something that the creepy old man down
the street did having it done to me by
another young boy confused me I didn't
know what to call it or how to describe
it I was 7 years
old for these reasons I told no
one yeah that's interesting that's
something I wasn't even going to put in
my book um at all because I I did I I
didn't you know very few people ever
knew that and uh Louis my co-author
really said hey man you should probably
put this in your book because it could
help a lot of men uh I just didn't feel
like so my father he died without
knowing it ever
happened it was uh I had a lot of
morality back then and uh I still do now
but at a point in my life I shut down
caring because I had to shut down caring
because as long as I cared I wouldn't be
able to live and he had me uh you know
touch him and I I wasn't ready and and
and in my mind I did take part in it
right I did do it when I when I did it I
wasn't thinking I was seven I wasn't
thinking sexually you know he was the
leader uh I was just doing what he told
me to do and uh man that messed me up uh
I I I still remember it vividly I went
home that night and I I woke up and I
came downstairs and I was crying and I
told my mother I had a headache and I
remember I was holding my little stuff I
had a goofy stuff down animal and I
thought I was going to hell for sure God
was going to take me to hell but it
introduced me to sexuality at a very
very young age so it almost made me
become sort of a a sexual deviant within
my own right I I understood what certain
things were uh
never I would watch movies and watch
even cartoons and start feeling a
certain way and I I I found like the
thought of sex would get me away from
from uh the pain that I was in you know
I I so if my parents were fighting you
know uh it's crazy to say you know I I I
I started uh I was touching myself at a
very young age anytime something will go
wrong hey get out of here and go
pleasure yourself and it became almost
like a form of therapy and that's very
very dangerous
because you don't understand what's
going on and and you equate it with
Madness actually because the only time
you think of sexual things is simply not
to feel good sexually but it's to to
feel good mentally to get away from the
other pain that you're currently dealing
with in your life like my father would
drink alcohol or shoot heroin it was
different for me and uh that really
affected me in my life but it affected
me most because it weighed so heavily on
me for so long that I made myself I had
to turn off a switch and become cold
I I had to stop caring about things I I
always said who I wanted to be in this
world was a much different person than I
ended up being and it's not until right
now in you know being 40 41 where I
could I could start being who I truly
feel I am you know uh because I was such
a soft kid and I had to force myself to
become harder not care more without
feeling because as long as I had feeling
or care compassion I would I would
suffer from my own sins well his sins
that he cast upon me but I felt they
were my sins so I had to make myself
almost heartless you know and I actually
started flirting
with Satan you know I I I read the
the the the Commandments of the Satanic
Bible and stuff like this and when you
just read them like how old are you when
you're doing this oh I'm 12 13 you know
I Lov Jesus but I where where did you
get the freaking Satanic Bible from when
13 years I would go to the library uh
the library is 400 meters from my house
you know and I what town was this in
Bayville okay bville New Jersey uh and I
would just research things you know and
I start re researching in high school
like uh ancient Aramaic like the true
language of of Jesus Christ and the lost
Gospel of St Thomas I started getting
really drawn into religion uh spirit
neity and there's some things you just
shouldn't understand you know and what's
crazy is that the Commandments of
Satanic Bible if you just read them they
sound pretty good you know and that's
exactly how you they get a hold of you
what they want them to sound you know
exactly and then uh this went all the
way through into my college Years and
and then I realized I was just getting
darker and darker and darker and uh I
was lost as as a human you know I
thought I was who I was supposed to be
but who I was supposed to be was just
the shell of a man you know and and and
you already mentioned like you're
playing and you talk about in the book
and by the way get the book I'm going to
like read like 3% of the book today so
much information in here and the way you
wrote it I talked about it before we hit
record but it's it's a written in a very
literary way it's a very the way it's
put together the way your co-writer Lou
Louie wrote it it's like it's it's good
it's a great book so get the book you
know you start talking about the fact
that you were playing Sports you could
dunk mhm which yeah which I could touch
fou I Could Touch the rim uh from the
foul line my junior year in high school
damun you know I high jumped 6'5 my
junior year in high school so I I could
uh I could jump really well damn you
some you had some bounce you got me yeah
yeah and your and your best long dble
was 2210 2210 but I fouled and that's
after I tore my ACL my junior year I
came back with the torn ACL uh but I Tor
my ACL in my my opposite my right leg my
jumping leg was my left leg but uh I
foued about 70% of the time and I kid
you not man this one time and it was a
home meat I must have fouled by a hair
and uh oh I'm so angry it still bothers
me till this day we measured it out we
measured it out and it was
243 uh I F on all my best jumps so I
remember when I got the long the when I
broke that School record the day my dad
overdosed I actually I didn't want to
foul so I slowed up up
before the mark and then I jumped and I
thought it was a horrible jump but I
remember I felt a good pop and it was
2210 man and I was going against a kid
named vmba bukula who was also a he was
a 24 foot long jumper and uh I beat him
that day and everybody chair when I got
it he's like what' you just jump what
you cuz we were buddies I was like a it
was a 19 foot jump I didn't tell him
what it was you know back him off a
little bit exactly he was an athlete boy
yeah I got lucky that day 652 high jump
that's good my brother jump J Jump
64 legit what was your long jump long
jump 217 my bet it's a great jump yeah
so 2210 that's no joke not joke what's
like a what's olympic record material
291 is the world record by Mike pow or
no 294 and a half by Mike pow but they
say Carl Lewis fouled on a jump that was
over 30
feet dang and then there was like a 8
foot high jump right yes 8 foot uh
Javier Sodom from Cuba eight feet in the
high jump yeah that's but we're talking
high school though you know for our
numbers so let's let's face it damn and
that's what you said you were just like
kind of addicted to training what was
your train were you training like when
you look at what the freaking
unbelievable training that people get
now what did your training compare to
like to that to to what you did back
then so basically you know old school
like I had a bar uh and some weights I
would do a lot of cleaning jerks I would
do a lot of push-ups I would do a lot of
uh just sit-ups on the on the board with
weighted like weighted sit-ups and then
I would do a lot of Sprints all the time
uh so that's basically all it was like a
lot of clean and jerks my grandfather
was really really big into lifting he
was a lighter guy like 190 but he would
bend the railroad spikes uh he would do
chinups with his fingertips uh he was a
state champion wrestler from
Pennsylvania and I'm the weakest one in
my family by far uh on both sides
actually my cousin I posted not too long
ago my first cousin on my mom side he's
uh you know 63 240 and just shredded
he's a Penn State linebacker and uh yeah
I got the my dad was short but stocky so
I didn't grow as tall as I I wanted to I
I say I'm six foot but I'm not but uh
yeah I just usually do a lot of I would
clean like three four times a week do a
lot of cleaning jerks that was my base
cleaning jerks cleaning jerks I would
love them uh I I still feel to this day
cleans are one of the best exercises you
could do it just gets everything so I do
a lot of Dynamic exercises and a lot of
Sprints uh a lot of Plyometrics I would
do you know believe it or not I wouldn't
change if I was to do it all over again
I wouldn't change I would probably do
less than I did but the the exercise I
still believe in the core exercises you
know like if you want to get big you
should squat bench bent over row push
press you know the basic things I think
strength and conditioning nowadays uh
there's a lot that goes into it you know
you see all the ropes into this into
that but I don't know how much I would
have got into that even if it was
available to me back then I think
lifting is always like a supplement to
your main sport whatever it may be no I
think I I think that's awesome if like
that's what I would say you would be
doing today if you were in those sports
like gas sprinting petrics doing clean
like those are the kind of core things
I'm impressed that you had that stuff
and that you were doing that stuff even
back then yeah my dad really helped me
with that stuff he knew how to exercise
uh and so did my grandfather so I was
blessed in that sense he would show me
what to do at a young age and then he
wouldn't stay with me and do it he was
always supposed to do it with me but he
wouldn't but I just stayed disciplined
enough to uh always disciplined you know
always disciplin to do what I was
supposed to do whether I felt like it or
not that was imperative you know and
that's one thing I've always done uh and
I think really in order to reach success
whatever success is ultimately my
definition of success is finding
happiness right but I think discipline
is imperative you know I haven't been
motivated in
years motivation is going to get get you
bar yes uh so you end up getting a
scholarship uh for for what for track
and field yeah the long jump and um and
you end up going to M how do you say
mmth University mouth University and
when you get there uh you say I didn't
drink at all in college or for several
years thereafter that's not easy to pull
off in college by the way but growing up
with my alcoholic father I developed a
hatred for alcohol my primary release
from life was still pain Sports and
self-inflicted adversity and I there's a
point that you talk about here where you
basically you say I heated up a metal
coat hanger this when you're 16 years
old I heated up a metal coat hanger in
the shape of a cross and branded it into
my shoulder so you I still have the
cross oh damn I did that when I was 16
and in my mind is we're supposed to feel
like you know I'm a spiritual guy and
Jesus was crucified he was brutally
beaten and murdered and he felt so much
pain so I still believe till this like
if I was allowed to do this without
being looked at as a psychopath you know
how you get the guys to whip their backs
and stuff like this like I feel it's
important for me to have felt pain
physically you know
uh I I think there's Beauty in it you
know especially when things get too
comfortable if we're too comfortable we
don't feel pain I feel it's fake it's
not real like I for me pain made me feel
like uh I was alive still and also at
the same time it it forced me to to stay
disciplined like I I I actually have
burn marks all over my body and every
time and I this is so foolish to do you
know it's not a smart thing to do but
I'm just telling you how my mindset used
to be if I would push I I would heat a
hanger and I would push it into my skin
if I would Flinch at all I would have to
do it again you know so I would do it
until I was able to do it and stay stoic
while doing it uh and again when you
look at it the psychological reasons
probably because I was forced to think
about nothing else but that exact thing
that was happening so I wasn't able to
to think about The Madness of my life I
was just only forced to think about the
pain at that moment now I could find the
same benefits from focusing on my
breathing you know what I mean like when
you do the Box breathing I could find
the benefits in that so man there's a
lot better ways to do it but uh what
were you listening to for
music all different kinds believe it or
not I would listen to a lot of like uh I
always listen to rap uh some alternative
I was more rap but I would listen to a
lot of like uh like the the
spiritual music like it's it's almost
like creepy church music sometimes when
I would get into these moments uh it's
like musical there is one uh I mean I
could sing and I'm not gonna but it's uh
it's pretty interesting I like all kinds
of music but I I really liked and I
listen you know a lot of the rap that I
used to listen to you know like the90s
rap it's very dark you know like Onyx uh
uh you know there's a lot of stuff like
the Ghetto Boys uh when some of their
raps were very very dark you know and
they actually talk about demonic things
and uh what you listen to is important
you know everything around you whether
you realize it or not has an influence
on you if you don't realize it you know
if you don't realize it it could affect
you and I think that really happened to
me and I think just what I was drawn to
were all the things that made me feel
tough didn't allow me to feel weak
anymore you know cuz my dad would always
tell me your day will come son your day
will come and uh I remember I remember
the Rock incident very very well but
there was another incident I was a
freshman in high school we went to a
party and this big football player for
no reason he tried to attack he was a
junior he tried to attack my friend and
I and we quick they got us out of the
party he's just being a tough guy he was
drunk and then whatever I didn't think
nothing of it he was large he was a big
guy um the next year we're at my buddy's
house and everybody were putting on the
boxing gloves boxing and I always my dad
taught me how to throw hands at a
younger age I'm more comfortable
throwing pun punches that I am Jiu-Jitsu
and uh they said hey why don't you I
almost said his name why don't you in
Tom box I'll do it I'll do it so I was
like yeah I'll do it too and uh man I I
uh I tore his face up he was leaking
everywhere he was so there were I
remember there was I went home and there
was blood on my shirt and my mom was
like and I was like don't ask me
questions you know and uh that was that
was a time in high school my my
sophomore where everything changed CU
everyone saw that beating and he kept
trying to stop but I wouldn't let him
stop I was hitting him just hard enough
to where he really couldn't quit right
but just hard enough to also open him up
a little bit uh there was more so like a
a broken nose he had but there a lot of
blood comes with a broken nose and I
remember that day everything my dad said
you know your your time will come if you
stay patient my day came that day that
was a good day and I didn't have to
fight him in a real way to actually
really hurt him it was kind of you know
we had gloves on so it it was a
beautiful moment I really like that
combat too exactly exactly uh when
you're in colge so now you're going to
college um you what you you tore your
ACL is that what happened in college I
tore myl in high school and I tore all
the ligaments in my ankle in college and
my jumping ankle and after I did that
man I just never had that pop again I
couldn't get I couldn't get past 19 ft
did you get surgery on it I didn't I
should have but I didn't but I also
heard if I got surgery at that time when
you get ankle surgery at that time I
don't know how it is now it takes away a
lot of your Mobility so you'll have
strength in your foot but you need
dexterity and mobility in order to jump
in order to push so I didn't do it I I
don't think anyone could come back as a
long jumper after having that kind of
ankle injury how did you get the ankle
injury playing basketball I rolled my
ankle playing basketball that the most
painful I every i' I tore my ACL LCL
miniscus my right knee I have 95% of my
miniscus removed on my left knee I need
two shoulder Replacements I'm going to
wayist to well again uh next next week
to get stem cells which helped me
tremendously because I have two torn
rotator cuffs and two labrums broke my
nose three times broke my hand three
times ripped my hamstring off my
buttbone had a a pin surgically inserted
in my toe uh tore my bicep dislocated my
elbow and the most painful thing oh and
I slip my disc in my back the most
painful thing I ever did was tear my
ligaments in my ankle that was horrific
man that pain was just really bad it w
and and it hurt forever like it hurt for
a long time you know
and is that what kind of that's how you
kind of started venturing towards
martial arts yeah I started as a young
man as a young boy I would do
Taekwondo uh when I was like five or six
so I actually went back I didn't know
anything and I went back to taekwondo at
like 19 when I tore my ligaments and uh
I just kept getting in trouble I would
go to competitions and you know the Tao
that I was involved there wasn't full
contact so if you hit too hard you get
in trouble so I kept getting disqualify
for hitting too hard so I so I found a
school across the street named Tong
Dragon Eric Cologne was the instructor
uh great guy real sweet guy but at that
time they didn't have any MMA fighters
they did some shoot fighting uh which
was open hand um I was training for just
a couple months I I wasn't even a belt
in Jiu-Jitsu and I was there're like oh
reality fighting is coming up uh you
want to jump in your opponent's his name
is Richard Thomas he has no fights but
he was a marine he has no fights
sure I'll do it he has no fights no
problem a week before the fight Richard
Thomas got hurt and they said hey David
trelli he his opponent got hurt you know
he his record at seven and three uh he
has 10 fights but you know he's old he's
35 he's old you could beat him and I oh
sure at that time I thought I could do
anything I realized at that moment when
I saw him before we walked out that I
was in trouble and I started trying to
pump myself up you know and it just
didn't work out well I got uh they
stopped the fight they stopped the fight
Cas see literally rained down I didn't
tap or nothing I took that whooping but
man my nose got broke my eyes were
swollen shut I look like I was from the
you ever see Star Wars and their head
connects to their nose I look like that
for like I remember I went to college
and next I went to school the next day
and people were looking at me like man
what is wrong with this guy and I was a
learning experience and then I stayed
there like a few more months and then I
heard Ricardo Al's name and uh I found
Ricardo and Kurt pelo and I started
training with them you you write in here
about the you say I remember rolling
with a purple belt in my first day he
was probably 150 lb soaking wet how's
that wakeup call man he tapped me like
77 times it was so annoying and
frustrating and I and I just felt like
such a little weasel you know like I was
like 195 and he just kept armar every an
arm bar every time every time and you
know when you don't really know the
sensitivity of a submission at first you
let it go for a while I I think there's
two types of people they either tap
right away or they tap right before it's
about to get broke and I was tapping
right before it's about to get broke and
when that happened to me I think there's
two different ways to react there's the
people who say you know what I'd rather
just get off these mats look in the
mirror and lie to myself or I'm going to
go home look in the mirror and and tell
myself the truth and the truth is you
don't know anything you're an infant on
these mats and I said I How Could I Live
how could I survive knowing there's such
tiny little men that could do whatever
they want to me beat me just like I'm a
small infant you know so I I got
addicted man I got addicted it's a crazy
experience especially I mean think about
how athletic you are as a human being
that has a 23t freaking long jump and
you can jump 6 feet like that's an
athletic dude who's been training uh for
athleticism his whole life and a little
150 pound you you give him I won't read
it but you give some like description
like this guy was a nerd you know 100%
nerd you're just like okay cool I'm
going to smash this guy you just and not
only an athlete like I grew up fighting
I fought a lot so I thought I I was like
I guess you would consider me a tough
Street Fighter you know I I got in a few
fights good ones but man it's just such
a different world and you truly don't
understand you don't know what you don't
know you know so when when you tell
people you tell grown men like you will
literally get pinned like a like a small
child they don't get it well if I'm
allowed to bite if I'm we're allowed to
bite too go ahead B I got teeth too go
ahead you know what I mean exactly go
ahead all you do is make people mad dude
that's it you're not going to do
anything but get us annoyed you know and
uh it it's such a wakeup call like as a
man I mean let's just say as an adult
like whether my profession was Jiu-Jitsu
or not I I would not be able to walk
around knowing I'm so helpless hand to
hand you know I just couldn't do it and
I'm not stupid like I have a buddy Nick
he was a marine Raider uh and I'm like
listen man you drop us off in the woods
naked you're going to live I'm going to
die right and you put us put us in a
room oneon-one I'll be okay you know so
I know my limits but at the same time
what I could control I I definitely want
to have as much control over as
possible yeah uh so you mentioned Kurt
pelino like freaking classic old school
uh fighter and you say this in the book
I was invited to train with Kurt Kurt's
teacher Ricardo Alam Ricardo was a
Jiu-Jitsu black belt there was a
Mystique about him for one he had
already fought in the UFC and he was
turning his attention toward king of
pancreas promotion in Japan also he's
the first Brazilian I had ever met
Ricardo did not live up to The
Stereotype of an easygoing Brazilian I
remember he was serious and intense he
was henzo Gracie's first black belt and
it's not an exaggeration to call him one
of the top fighters in the world at the
time so this is what you roll into you
start so did you start training with
Ricardo almea at that time so first I
started training with Kurt cuz he had a
school in Tom Tom rver so I realized if
I wanted to take it to the next level I
had to train with somebody who's done it
and at the time Kurt was a PanAm
champion in the blue Bel division uh
which was huge as an American at that
time you know it was only Brazilians
winning what year is this man this has
to be like 2004
2003 uh yeah and then I started training
with Ricardo through Kurt but Kurt was
my instructor at the time and he was a
blue belt as tough as they come he was
such a tough he was a jersey wrestler
super tough one of the strongest humans
I felt and that was another huge wakeup
call because I started training with him
like a few months after I was already
training so I started doing good at the
local school I was one of the top guys
in the local school then I went on train
with Kurt and again I was an infant all
over again you know so like how could I
leave this guy when he just knows so
much you know and uh I ended up
traveling I I became very close with
Kurt traveled to Japan with him uh
cornered him in the king of pancreas and
you know Kurt his career took off he he
fought in the UFC he did well we we
ended up parting ways uh he ended up
moving to Florida and training with
American top team and I stated with
Ricardo but uh yeah I learned a lot from
him man so so now you end up you got
like you're basically brought into the
henzo clan at this Jun you got hyen
Gracie half Gracie hoder Gracie you got
esea like there's some some people
you're training with that are like
they're the best guys in the world at
the time yeah my main so I quickly
became one of their main uh I used to
call myself a sparring partner but I was
just basically a beat up dummy right I
was a tough kid who could get up but
again over and over and over first time
I met Ricardo he was sparring at Curts
and uh he was going to fight Nate
markhart and he needed a sparring
partner and I was like I'll do it and uh
he literally like knocked me out of my
feet woke me up again from the double
Lake he put me on my head with and uh I
got up and I man this is amazing and
they're like we like this guy you know
he he could be good for us so uh I was h
was main sparring partner when he was
going to fight BJ Penn so we had it
would the training room was me Kurt
pelino Dante Rivera Ricardo hyen Gracie
half Gracie and a few others and uh bro
that's a room right there boy man I
remember
hyen hyen took a liking to me he would
never like talk to me but he would walk
up to me and like rub my face and I
would just sit there and let him caress
my face right and then I would bow and
uh then half I remember would get angry
with me he wouldn't wear headgear so I
never wanted to hit him hard in the head
but then if I didn't hit him he would
get furious but then if I hit him he
would get fuy so like you're just
getting your ass whoop regardless you
know but it was such a great experience
and then Dante and I we would always we
would always get into it and and Ricardo
Halen hyen they would find great
entertainment in our in our sparring
matches so we would just literally put
on MMA gloves and beat the heck out of
each other man like we would just fight
like MMA
fights every every day it was the
craziest thing ever that's I say all the
injuries I've had of course I have all
these injuries I didn't train smart well
they're so much smarter about training
now my we were back in the day I mean we
did the same thing like it was to train
for an MMA fight what would you do MMA
fight that's what we do yeah well we're
going to fight small gloves no headgear
let's go rock and roll that's how we're
doing it and you do that you know we do
that three four five times a week bro
hard I mean ignorant yes I I I I was
sparring in Trenton and Camden and
Philly boxing and when you go to boxing
gyms it's not a Jiu-Jitsu gym like
you're not talking to your sparring
partner beforehand they want to they
want to smash your face and especially
if you're an MMA guy especially if
you're a white boy walking in the Philly
you know and uh I can't tell you how
many times I've been concussed in the
boxing gym you know like so many times
I've tooken some whoopings it's crazy
man I would I don't people say do you
miss MMA I miss MMA as much as I miss a
sore throat right that's how much I miss
Miss
MMA uh there's a little bit of a
deviation here in the book you at this
time you're like start realizing you
maybe want to find someone to like like
a female to be with you like join a
dating site you kind of talk about some
of that stuff and pretty quickly you you
meet a meet a girl and um she gets
pregnant um you use the term Elation and
Terror when you find out that your
girl's pregnant especially when I found
out I was having a daughter my God bro
you know and yeah she got pregnant
really quick and I tried to you know I
had my own home at the time cuz I opened
my academy uh I was very successful with
it I didn't have an association yet but
I had my own home so she moved from
Edison to my house and we were just two
still are two separate people you know
but we both tried to do the right thing
and be there and you know raise our
child together and I thought like listen
she's pregnant she's having my child
she's having isab Bell there's no way
we're ever not we're going to make it
work regardless if my parents made it
work we can make it work so she got
pregnant again a few years later and my
son Thomas but uh we both realized uh
you know like it's really hard living
with someone when you're two completely
different humans no matter who's wrong
or who's right sometimes you just got to
stop trying to figure out who's right
and who's wrong and you just got to
accept things are what they are right
there there's no point in trying to have
someone understand your point because
they see things through their eyes you
know so we realize it's best that we go
our separate ways so we did you know I
still have my kids 50 50 to 60% of the
time uh I gave her my home I walked away
from it I gave it to her I got another
smaller home built next to my parents uh
and it's just much easier that way I'm
I'm a much better father this way
because I because when I'm with my kids
I'm 100% with them you know I'm a very
Hands-On dad and uh it forces me to do
the things that I wasn't doing before
like every morning I got to get them
ready for school I have to pack their
lunch I have to do these things I have
to brush my son's teeth like things that
dads generally don't do when you're
living with their mother you know
there's there's usually like a mother's
role and a father's role to where now I
have to play both roles which I'm
thankful it it was that divorce was
definitely the hardest probably the
hardest thing in my life right but now I
I realize how thankful I am that my my
kids my kids never saw their mother and
I argue they you know bickering yes but
they never heard me raise their voice to
their mother and my my daughter's old
enough now to know how my life used to
be and she's very thankful that uh she
didn't have to see these things you know
so things work out the way they're
supposed to in the end for
sure and speaking of things working out
you after that first MMA fight that you
described where you got basically tko'ed
and the ref sto that you you were like
I'm going back to MMA you get a amateur
MMA fight um against some guy who you
freaking tow hold pretty quick pretty
simple pretty
straightforward uh and then and then you
get
into ADCC which um and you talk about in
the book you give it some explanation
most people that listen to this podcast
will know what ADCC is if you don't ADCC
is like the Olympics of submission
grappling yeah it's the whole world the
best competitors in the world are going
to get invited or make it through trials
to get to this stage which is the ADCC
World Championships they're held in
different places around the world but um
and so you're you're now part of this
team and you say in the book in those
days each professional Jiu-Jitsu
organization could send a single
competitor to the trials and at Team
henzo Gracie it was determined that the
best way to choose our trials combatant
was to fight it out amongst ourselves
yes you read that right a tournament to
determine who could compete in the
tournament that determined who would
compete in the tournament yes we had
wrestle off yeah and that's what the
whole world is doing so the whole world
is narrowing down who who's going to
represent there who's going to represent
their team and then from that team
you're going to go and fight in the
trials and if you win the trials in your
geographical region which is like North
American trials South American European
trials and if you win those and then
there's also a combination of people
that have won ADCC in the past or place
in the past then they get like an
automatic yeah there's eight invitees
and eight
qualifiers in the whole entire world so
you guys decide what year is this what
year is your first ADCC 2009 okay yeah
so I won the trials in 2008 yep and yeah
you it's pretty cool it's actually you
say like hey this is the in-house
tournament that you guys have at henzo
was like hey it's not
about it's not a kiss and tell situation
like what happens happens exactly and in
the book you're like hey what happened
happened and I I'm going so you don't go
it's one of the few areas in the book
where you don't go to much detail he's
like hey dude we don't kiss and tell bro
that's what's happening and I'm still so
big on that man you know like I I tell
my students
too you should not be and I see it all
the time nowadays people are literally
like they're texting about who they're
tapping and training and this and that
that's a great way to lose trust in your
training Partners you know I was very
thankful at the time that I was able to
represent my team like that was a feet
within itself man represent you know to
represent hzo was like a dream come true
and before that like I I dedicated
everything to Jitsu after that MMA fight
uh and I ended up like winning the pans
the Nationals the noi worlds I Glover
and I actually he won as a black belt
and I won as a brown belt the first nogi
worlds ever he won the first noi worlds
as black belt I won the first noi worlds
as brown belt that's when I think I met
him oh Jeffy Glover yep Jeff Glover and
uh always a mad man always a mad man and
uh yeah I I I won I ended up going to
Barcelona what a wakeup call just a
great experience that was to be among
Legends right when your your Idols
become your Rivals and it was a it was a
crazy thing to see uh Dean did Dean he
did so this is 2009 2009 Barcelona so I
think Dean just got the invite yeah of
course because he had won in 2003 won
Super fight in 2005 and I think he was
injured in 2007 or something like that
so 2009 he might have just gotten the
invite yeah he didn't have to Tri I know
he didn't have to the trials so he
didn't have to do the trials so it's
interesting so we had him and Penny
Thomas so Penny Thomas Penny yeah she
was here at Victory and she was our kids
teacher and you know training we trained
with her of course too but so it was and
actually it was Penny th so the trip to
Barcelona was me Penny Thomas Dean liser
and Seth Stone so Seth Stone was had
been hanging out with penny at the time
and so I was like hey bro you know like
I'm going to Barcelona want to come he's
like sign me up you know that's the kind
of setstone activities that was going
down so setstone was like my my best
friend and uh you know he did Jiu-Jitsu
and everything but he was dating penny
at the time I remember her man she was
so tough oh yeah she's awesome and so
that's who showed up so we all flew over
there and I remember Dean
he he comes down and he's wearing a a a
tank top like a really nice tank top and
it just says UFC and giant letters like
on the front of it it was like one of
those UFC uh what was the show he was on
uh Ultimate Fighter it was like one of
those I mean it's just literally like 9
in U and Dean is Dean is enormous too
yeah he's enormous and I look at Dean
and I go trying to stay low profile
are cuz there's nothing low profile
about that freaking shirt um so so
that's what you now did you have you had
a meniscus tear going into this uh is
that right I had a meniscus tear going
in into uh I believe I did then I
definitely had one going into 2017 but I
I basically I've always been hurt I
think everyone's always hurt going into
their competitions so many injuries over
the years um that ADCC was tough because
my my first match was uh Cyborg and the
whole entire match they gave cyborg a
negative one and me zero right so that I
was on top the entire time so I I
thought I was the Victor you know we had
a scramble at the end uh no one scor we
get up after the match and they're like
wait a second oh we thought you were
Cyborg and he was Tom so they switched
the negative point and they gave him the
victory by negative like a man that was
so and that actually then I competed
against gval in the absolute Division I
lost three to zero but that that mess up
in ADCC where I got ripped off that kind
of drove me back to MMA so I kind of I I
left uh Jiu-Jitsu for a few years I
figured I need more control if I'm if I
was able to knock him out I would have
been okay you know what I mean but uh
yeah it was a great experience there
were so many great that's when Jack went
against
Dale uh in the super fight okay yeah
that's when braia won the absolute
division yeah and Dean in the ADCC in
Barcelona Dean he he won a couple
matches and then he went against Vinnie
magal Vinnie hell yeah yeah and there
was z z at the end of um whatever
overtime and Regulation and and Vinnie
got the KN they gave it to Vinnie that's
when Vinnie won yeah and I mean Vinnie
bro that guy's not tapping no like he's
not tapping that's when verdum B caught
him in that arar and Dean had you know
put heel hooks on him and stuff like
that and he's just like he he's not
tapping it was insane maybees does he
have like Jeff Glover level flexibility
or something Vin mag he must I think
Gordon heel hooked him right I think he
got heel hooked eventually by one person
yes Gordon with an inversion but we
didn't think it was possible before that
and I might be wrong Vinnie if if he
didn't he'll hook you I'm sorry I know I
know Vinnie has a victory over Gordon I
think he's like the last one to beat
Gordon that I remember he passed his
guard in some kind of event I forget
what the event was years ago but just
think about what we're saying right now
these are the people that are competing
in ADCC it's like Dean lster Vinnie
magal like just total it's it's freaking
monsters
um
so you're going back to MMA my my I'm
going to the book here my life was a
training montage 4 days a week I would
wake up at 4:30 and drive an hour to
Ricardo's house from there we drive an
hour and a half to gym for 2hour
training session after that we drive an
hour and a half to hzo Academy New York
another two-hour training session drive
back to Ricardo's house take a nap train
for another hour and drive back home I'd
do this four days a week the other three
I needed to make money took up becoming
a school teacher I had finished college
with my degree in education I took a a
job at a special education school right
out of college teaching severely
autistic children so that's what you
were doing yes so that training session
was all throughout the summer uh not
exaggerated at all and then the other
two days a week I would travel to
Bricktown and uh that's like 45 minutes
or 40 minutes from me in train with a
guy Bill Scott and then come the school
year I would teach all day and then
right after the school day was over I
would drive to Ricardos which is still
an hour hour and a half away I would
take two classes teach a class and I
would come home I would get home around
11:00 and then I do the same thing all
over again I would do that Monday
through Thursday and then Friday I would
train in Bricktown so it was a really
hectic crazy schedule but I knew I had
to drive if I wanted to get the training
that I needed but I also knew I couldn't
keep up being a a school teacher and
have this schedule indefinitely and
compete at a high level and at that time
I thought competition was everything I
didn't even think about like hey you
want to be a school owner and this and
that I just literally one day I said hey
I would love to not have a boss anymore
MH although as a school owner your
students become your boss Believe It or
Not way it so you always have a boss but
I wanted to do something that I love to
do my biggest problem as as working in
the real world was people
who people who didn't take care of
themselves physically uh like bossing me
around and listen it it shouldn't have
affected me but it did you know it
really did I was like how are you going
to tell me what we call that a grudge
yeah like how are you GNA tell me what
to do when you you can't even beat your
your diet you know what I mean and and I
realize that way of thinking is immature
because you could learn from anybody but
for me if the I don't take advice from
people unless I really know that they've
done it or they could teach me something
because if you take advice from just
everybody and anyone you're going to be
really confused you know so I was like I
got to get out of here man this is just
no good and the pettiness that these
teachers would argue about and talk
about and I'm like man pick and choose
your battles you're making mountains out
of mole Hills and I I found that a lot
at that time the
teachers a lot of them really didn't
like the kids and that would I was young
I I was I was 22 and that would that
would bother me like how are you going
to talk badly about this little kid
because here's the thing this little kid
you don't know what he's going through
at home you know and this is this is his
only shot right at a life and and one of
the kids I actually was a student
teacher for I saw he overdosed on drugs
two years ago you know and I had him
when he was 6 years old and then another
kid I had when he was 8 years old we
still keep in touch I just sent him a my
my my Garmin watch not too long ago he
just crashed his truck I sent to my
Garmin watch and and he got so happy and
it made his day and I still kept contact
with him you know so I think a lot of
the teachers didn't realize some do many
do that you literally could be a pivotal
moment in a child's life you know you're
the reason why they push forward or the
reason why they don't and for me I
always looked at kids as I wanted to
help them you know so I figured I could
still help if I do things my way teach I
could help them to strangle and break
bones rather than learn two plus
two uh you also say this in the book
here um there was a price to pay for all
this you're talking about your training
and how you're living at the time I'd
love to tell you that I was on purpose
doing what I love and it's true I felt
like fighting was my calling even if I
didn't yet see the pathway to Fame and
Fortune no one was getting rich off of
fighting back then but at the same time
I knew I was unwell my depression that I
had battled with for most of my life had
never really gone away in fact maybe it
had gotten worse my loneliness had also
grown I probably don't have to tell you
that the guys I was seeing day in and
day out were not the most emotionally
open people they weren't bad guys in
fact some of them might have even been
supportive and helpful had I spoken to
them but in their world fighting and
training were solutions to everything
the constant War we waged at the gym was
was a way to deal with our various
issues in desperation I went to my
mother I told her I needed help that
something was wrong with me she was 100%
supportive and on a Friday morning I
checked myself into one of those places
that they never call a mental hospital
but that's what it
was yes now this happened actually in my
senior year in college before I became a
school teacher and guys when I tell you
I was
uh you ever hear when you're like you're
awake but you can't really get like
you're dreaming but you see what's going
around it's called something like you're
awake but you can't move you're it's
sleep power power you're like paralyzing
your sleep I forget what it's called
it's a thing and that was happening to
me a lot and uh it actually sounds
comical like there was a vent in my
college room and the vent would make
noises and stuff and I actually I was
getting so far gone and this is when I
was also really really really out the
library every day trying to like
decipher for ancient Aramaic and
understand all these things and there's
such a fine line between good and evil
and when you read the Bible a lot of the
things that were written in the B people
forget it was written thousands of years
ago things are deciphered much different
and I also say I'm not going to get into
it but you know man ultimately wrote the
Bible what what happens when if you tell
me some if I tell you something then you
tell jao something by the time it gets
to this person it's probably going to be
a little different than what I initially
said so people put their spin on things
and when you take everything so literal
sometimes you know I started to think
you know and if you look into the Old
Testament like violence is not frowned
upon you know I started to think I was
doing wrong by not like eliminating bad
people right and I I would I to go
straight
dexur
100% 100% And I was I would actually get
to
sleep be paralyzed in my sleep look at
the vent and I was starting to like get
this not that I would hear and actual
voice but like like an urge like telling
me to go do what I know I'm supposed to
yes just like Dexter and I realized like
how close I was literally to being on
the front page of of the New York Post
that I just went postal and just took
out a bunch of people right like and I
knew like man you got to get help like
you you need help but the irony is when
I got help I realized once I stepped in
that mental hospital how much I really
didn't need help compared to some of
these people you know it was just it's
it's Madness in there what what people
are going through in there and I'll
never forget there was one moment that
really stuck out like there was this guy
in like a wheelchair but they had like
strapped him down and he was like trying
to wiggle his way out of the wheelchair
and there was another guy looking at him
and he started screaming it's like he's
wiggling he's wiggling and I was so
freaked out at the moment I was like get
me out of here I tried to check
heal yes yes I I tried to check myself
out they wouldn't let me check out I was
like my God I went in the room and I
started push pressing the chair in the
room like 400 times until I couldn't do
it anymore and I just laid down I was
like what have you got yourself into
right now and I wrote down she the The
woman there she told me write exactly
all your feelings and I wrote down my
feelings and I gave it to her she handed
it back to me she said listen I'm going
to give this back to you you're going to
burn it before you ever show anybody
because they will lock you up for a long
long time right uh she knew I wasn't
sick she knew I wasn't going to do those
things I still had the I I I I knew the
consequence of if I was to take action
and start offing bad people like Dexter
you're going to spend the rest of your
life in jail right uh so the consequence
outweighed my desire to do certain
things and then you know you start
thinking who the hell am I to judge
who's right and who's wrong I mean
there's certain people you just know
they're they're just not good people
people you know like uh but again the
irony in that is I still know my
molester till this day and I have no ill
will against him and that's odd that's
very very odd I don't understand it my
daughter asked me why as well because if
someone was ever to touch my children
you I know how I would handle that but I
I it's weird and and I ask myself why
don't I have anger or hate towards him
because that was such a pivotal moment
in my life that actually ruined my life
in many ways in many senses uh
why wouldn't I hate that guy why
wouldn't I hate that kid and and I think
a part of it's because personally I was
so used
to being abused and taking abuse maybe I
don't take it as personal or maybe I
look at him as he was abused I don't
know but I I that's still something I
can't figure out why don't I why don't I
hate him you know why don't I hate him I
don't know I mean I'm thankful that I I
don't but uh everything happens the way
it's supposed to be in the end I gather
the way I mean the way you write about
it in the book you have a very detached
perspective of being able to see I mean
you literally write in the book that
he's a victim too type thing you know
and that's a very uh detached
perspective for you to be able to get to
and I look at little me as a different
human like there's little Tom and then
there's Tom right like it's two two
separate people two different people I
you know I I couldn't remain little me
for an extended period of time and and
make it in this world you know you just
I couldn't do it I was too soft I was
too sensitive I was too caring I was too
abused I was too helpless uh so yeah I
did detach myself in many many ways I
detached myself completely from my
childhood uh and then I went through
like a a nomad state where I became kind
of I guess lost or I thought I was found
but I wasn't I was lost and then I think
it wasn't until my late 30s to where I
really
started finding out like I was
successful in monetary terms and you
know in my field but I mean again if you
think success is happiness I wasn't
successful until the last few years
right when I really figured out a lot of
things about myself and you know when
you don't compare yourself to other
people that's why I don't have any
interest in competition because I'm
obsessed with being better than who I
was but I don't really careed about
being better than that person or this
person but again I say irony a lot like
I tell my athletes I
said the irony of Jiu-Jitsu is you all
want to beat another person but in order
to beat another person you have to
dominate your own self first right so
once you can dominate yourself then you
can think about dominating that man and
chances are if you become the absolute
best version of yourself you're most
likely going to be better than a lot of
other people right because most people
aren't looking to become the best
version of themselves right they're not
looking to do so so if you want to be a
competitor how do you beat this person
and that person how you don't put your
focus on them you put your focus on
yourself you do everything that you
could do you control what you can
control cuz you can't control control
everything you could control yourself
right so when you become the best
version of yourself most likely that's
going to be good enough to succeed I
feel you know no doubt and what's
holding most people up isn't isn't their
opponent it's themselves it's that they
didn't train hard enough they didn't
humble themselves they didn't work on
their weaknesses they didn't go to train
when they needed to go train like that's
all because of them not cuz of their
opponent 100% the mind is either your
best friend or your worst enemy you know
and there is such a battle an eternal
struggle and then the worst is when you
you find your athletes at are just so
talented and so incredible and then they
get out there and you know how many
times we hear this person's a beast in
the training room but they just don't
compete well you know because they they
kind of freeze underneath the bright
lights and and I try to get into my
athletes mind like
listen it's your preparation that I'm
the most proud of how you prepare if you
do all the right things I'm super proud
of you now you winning in this
competition is just it's a gift that
you're giving to yourself and me to
celebrate all the the hard work that you
deserved to get that's why I'm very big
and I don't want the athlete that just
go out there and win without training I
I'm really not interested in that I want
someone who's willing to prepare to
sacrifice to put forth the effort so
then we could celebrate a worthy cause
you know we could celebrate something
that they earned something that I earned
working with them uh and that's that's
the beauty in Victory in competition and
when my athletes put in all the work and
then I know somebody beats them because
at the given time my athlete doesn't
show up mentally it breaks my heart uh
for some of my own selfish reasons for
sure but also because I know what they
did deserve you know uh last week all my
athletes they they just I said if you
just listen you will win if you listen
you will win they all listened it was an
event called Men of War and they all
just did phenomenal not one of them
allowed their opponent to to get off one
offensive technique and the thing is
Jiu-Jitsu so common to life because I
tell my athletes if you just focus I
actually heard Dean lisst say one time
he said if I could stay in the moment no
one could beat me if I could stay in the
moment what's the moment everybody wants
to win okay but before you win what do
you got to do you got to show up you
know step by step second by second
minute by minute match by match what do
you do in between matches how do you
breathe how do you recover so I tell my
athletes every time someone's grabbing
you every time someone's touching you
they're doing so for a reason you're
getting caught in a submission because
you're not reacting when someone takes
your back and strangles you don't just
say you got your back taken and
strangled how did they get to their back
they passed their guard they put their
hand on the place that you didn't
address so my athletes this time they
addressed every single grip every single
thing that the person then on my student
camera and he got a leg lock on a guy
eston eston's a known little he's a
killer man he's ranked seven in the
world at like 125 and I've never seen
this guy gets admitted before and he
didn't react Cameron got above the KNE
line his legs are like 18 inches this
kid so it's like impossible to leg lock
cam got above the knee line he didn't
react boom he got healed you know uh
Jiu-Jitsu works yeah man you know and
it's just like when when you really when
you take the approach in Jiu-Jitsu like
you should take in life it's going to be
very hard to not find success you know
step by step second by second address
everything don't overlook
anything yeah well these are the
lessons that they take a while to figure
out sometimes uh you know you you talk
about in the book and you kind of
mention like you won nationals you won
nogee Worlds at this time you're
training um with the henzo Gracie team
which includes people like Matt Sarah
George St Pierre Ricard Ricardo Alam and
you're like saying you're in that group
you know that was part of you were part
of that crew yeah and that's a freaking
badass place to be and so you say this
in the book I was starting to experience
real success but privately I floated in
and out of despair every win was a
relief from my depression but every win
was temporary my life was an
unsustainable formula fight and win to
distract myself take to take the edge
off when I couldn't compete The Edge
still needed to go away somehow in those
times my Outlets became less healthy I
would go to parties go to strip clubs
stay up all night anything to keep me
busy it would have forced me to it if
you would have forced me to sit on a
couch with nothing but my own thoughts I
might have gone insane many people say
they find themselves through martial
arts I was avoiding myself my own
private thoughts my past I needed every
tournament to be the biggest one
possible the one that would require 100%
of my focus and mental attention then I
wouldn't need to spend time with myself
but I also recognize that the cycle
would eventually end I couldn't compete
forever couldn't train forever my pain
would never stop coming from me it would
catch up with me I sometimes wondered if
death was the solution
yeah for sure I wasn't uh I went back to
that feeling of when I was a little boy
like who I had to become in order to
survive wasn't someone that I really
liked and when you don't like your own
self uh you get tired of living with
yourself so what do you do when you're
tired of living with yourself you stop
living with yourself you know so I
remember I was uh I I just I I wanted I
didn't want to be here no more you know
I went to the store I got a a rope I was
going to make a noose and I was going to
find a good tree to jump from and hang
myself from uh but I was too cowardly to
do it you know uh that's what it comes
down to but ultimately the cowardice
became a problem because I didn't want
anyone to find me I said well man what
if a little kid finds me and how's my
mom going to live I almost wanted my
father to feel that pain you know to
feel the pain that that he made me feel
uh so much you know uh but I didn't want
my mom to feel that pain
so I got over that you know and I didn't
end up killing myself and and I realized
I could never I could never do that
because you know while I said I was too
much of a coward to kill myself I didn't
want to be so much of a coward to not
face myself you know there's I would
rather be the the coward afraid to kill
myself than the coward to run to for
myself you know so I I really just I
started trying to find what would make
me
happy because winning wouldn't make me I
would be happy for like a day and then I
needed more and it's
like people ask me what are some of the
things you would have done differently
what I would have done is I would have
learned to stain the moment more and and
and celebrate my victories you know I
for me if I was celebrating a victory I
wasn't working hard towards the next one
and as soon as I would win I'd be on the
mats the next day training to to to win
the next one instead of being on the
mat's next day training because I love
Jiu-Jitsu I spent a lot of time training
to win rather than a lot of time
training to just love it like
competition has to be a consequence of
your love for Jiu-Jitsu you can't
compete to
win if you're only competing to win well
why don't you go do something that's
much easier on your body right if it's
just winning that you're addicted you
have to be addicted to Jiu-Jitsu you
know uh and you have to show up because
you love Jiu-Jitsu so athletes I try to
make it fun for them and the consequence
of their love for jiujitsu will be when
they step out on the under the bright
lights and they finally win uh but I
realized what really made me happy what
was teaching you know so I I I and it
genuinely made me happy helping people
and it's something that never left me it
wasn't fleeting you know one thing about
me I made it to I won three ADCC trials
in North America there's not many people
in history that have done that and I
also lost lost 3 adccs you know and I'll
go back when I was in in Little League I
I walked the I I struck out the last
batter to get into the Little League
World Series and then I walked the last
batter to lose the Little League World
Series and I always said to myself man
if I just would have won an ADCC well
you know okay if you just would have won
but did you win the absolute Division
and then if you won the absolute
division did you win the Super fight
then if you won the super fight did you
win the Super fight more than anyone
else ever won the Super fight it's Never
Enough It's never enough so just accept
the things that are you know and I think
a lot of the reasons why I didn't win
ADCC was my
own mental shortcoming to be quite
honest uh you know throughout the years
competing I I I've I've given up 12
points in in 18 years I wouldn't give up
position or things like that uh but when
it came to ADCC I didn't find a way
right right and uh for me to be able to
say that now and be okay with saying
that like no I wasn't Dean like Dean did
what I couldn't do you and that's okay
man I respect him for that I love him
for that good for you brother tell me
how it felt you know tell me how it felt
like because you find out who you are
and who I am I like who I am you know so
I said what I what made me happy was
finding out where could I Prosper the
most where could I do best and my best
is it's pretty good you know running a
school running an association you know I
have 64 Affiliates now I never looked
for an association but every school that
started associating under me that
actually because I have some schools
that associate with me they don't listen
to any advice ironically they don't grow
uh the schools that do they've all grown
by at least 35 40% so that's something
I'm proud about you know so I could sit
next to somebody and hear where they
flourished in life and then maybe they
could hear where I have but at the end
of the day if if you're not flourishing
in a in a sense of life that could
actually keep you feeling good for an
elongated period of time what does it
matter so I could go back and be
thankful now that I won the trials but I
can't live off that you know like one of
the reasons now you know over the last
few months I've leaned out a lot right
because I'm not competing now so when I
was still competing I wouldn't mind if
my weight would fluctuate here and there
because I'm still competing I'm still
kicking but it's okay if I get chubby
here and there right but now that I'm
not competing
I have to stay more disciplined to look
the part and and and to still I don't
want to say suffer because eating well
and staying fit is not suffering but to
remain disciplined in other aspects of
life so when I speak people want to
listen people want to hear what I have
to say rather than being the guy that
you know won the high school
championship and and want to talk about
that like oh when I won the trials in
2019 15 and 17 you don't want to be
Uncle Rico right from Napoleon Dynamite
Just out there like you know I could
have coach would to put me in boy that's
it and it's so easy to get caught up in
that and it's so easy that's why I find
a lot of MMA fighters that never retire
because they they're they're searching
for that moment again right to where
when I signed for 1fc again and I tore
my bicep I said God's trying to tell you
something brother you know I've never
been knocked out in a fight I've never
been finished in a fight and uh I don't
really want to be to be quite honest you
know seems like a good call yeah I I
don't need to go out on this you my last
fight was actually a great one I I
knocked out a guy Jason Lambert and it
was a walkway knockout and I got lucky
you know it easily could have been me
but like what what are we searching for
why are we trying to find something
that's fleeting why are we trying to
find something that doesn't last we need
to find things that last what lasts is
your impression that you make upon
people what your what what's going to
make my legacy last is my
Association my students
my ability to help other people open a
school and support their family who
cares who won the trials in 2016 there's
people who in the trials every two years
could we name all of them of course not
you know so I find serving you know
service giving back to people is
something that makes me happy and I'm
and and I guess for my own selfish
reasons I like to say I'm good at it I
guess that's the competitor within me
but again if you reach your own personal
best you're naturally going to find
greatness because most people I truly
don't I believe most people in this
world don't fight to find their best I
just truly believe they don't because I
don't think they realize how much
they're capable of
doing if they knew how much they could
achieve I think they would put in more
work well you you obviously you realize
this at some point I mean not only um
you know in the book you you end up
starting your own Academy yes um and you
talk about all this stuff in 4 months
you have 150 students you you grow real
quick from the first space that you had
you grow real quick you get a bunch of
students and you end up with 150
students in 4 months which means you can
quit your job uh and now you're kind of
like well on your way to to making
things happen you got Gary tonin shows
up start training with that Maniac crazy
guy man I remember the first day he
walked in he was a Helen he had long
ratty hair he had severe ad DHD like me
he couldn't look at me in the eyes every
single thing I would how old was he at
the time he was 15 or 16 damn I brought
I Gary trained with me strictly until he
was black belt uh he won adc's trials
under me he won a noi worlds two times
just with me uh he went to ADCC just
under me and then he started going to
school at Ruckers in new Bruns and that
was closer to the city and then he
that's when he started training in the
city with John and I say till this day
and I mean this if Gary just would have
stayed with me he undoubtedly would have
probably won three
adccs in boring fashion right John made
him
exciting to where Gary always had that
exciting style under me and I never
wanted it like he would he would win a
match like 72 to 47 and I'm like bro how
do you give up 47 points like what are
you doing right now so I didn't tell him
good job for the first time until after
he won the brown ball Worlds the second
time I didn't give him his bout after he
won the worlds the first time because I
didn't like the way he won right yeah so
he he uh got John allowed him to to I
guess be him you know a great example of
Gary's when ADCC
2017 the match for third place against
Vagner roacha Gary was like I'm not
competing in this to win I'm competing
in this to have fun I said Gary you're
up for a medal this is going to be the
first time you win an ADCC medal go win
the medal I don't care how boring it is
he's like I'm having fun he went out
there and he was Vagner took his back
from behind and Gary instead of
Defending he put his arms up in the air
like he was flying an airplane and
started like running around the M like
what what am I watching right now and he
started doing you know uh gr's out of it
he ended up losing the match cuz he just
had fun he's like hey I had fun so
that's him that's his happiness and I it
it it was hard for me to understand at
the time like if you're not winning how
are you happy right like I don't get it
right so yeah Gary found his exciting uh
legendary exciting style under John 100%
you know John's a Master with his
submissions and uh was able to flourish
in that sense I do believe positionally
Gary would have squeaked Out 3
adccs in a nice boring fashion under me
uh but you know what that wouldn't have
made Gary happy Gary won ADCC gold medal
being boring like Tom the blast he's not
happy you
know uh going back to the book here it
felt like almost everyone I knew in my
life was there my mother and father
henzo all of their students all of my
students it was around a 100 people all
gathered there for me in your lifetime
you rarely get to experience moments
where so many people are gathered just
for you not because you're going to give
them anything but because they just want
to be a part of your Moment henzo full
of his usual Charisma gave a Proud
speech totally off the cuff as usual he
knew exactly what to say with henzo his
words always took a backseat to his
Spirit hell
yeah hicard spoke next it was different
from henzo he couldn't make you laugh on
Q but he didn't try and be something he
wasn't if henzo was a happy warrior
hicard was the intense one at that time
hikaro was fighting in the UFC winning
fights and slowly climbing the ladder he
had assembled a legendary team including
guys like Frankie Edgar who is now being
seriously considered as a top Contender
for UFC title shot at the end of their
speeches they both tied a black belt
around my waist people cheered everyone
wanted hugs and pictures I felt happy
but as always something held me back on
100 people had just gathered to see me
succeed people that cared about me and
were happy for me I went to bed that
night in my new house that I had bought
I had a black belt I was a brown belt
Champion I had money I had friends but
as crazy as it sounds I felt incredibly
lonely yeah just a constant pit in my
stomach man and that's something I've
dealt with my entire life it was so
frustrating because you don't know what
is causing it's like an impending doom
you know and I think a lot of it stems
back to when I was younger when things
would go well I knew right around the
corner was something devastating about
to happen so I think I would always
worry about
something that was going to happen
terrible or I was always searching for
something else to negate something
terrible happening rather than just
staying in the moment like right now
when I got my black belt hey you got
your black belt you have your home
everything is good nothing else matters
the only thing that matters is right now
if you want a better tomorrow
you have to focus on today that's the
only way tomorrow you can't worry about
tomorrow you can't worry about the past
you could learn from the past I don't
believe not thinking about the past
while staying in the moment what I mean
when I say stay in the moment I I
believe when we look at the past we look
at it from a very objective point of
view to where I look at it at not from a
personal standpoint I look at it as like
I'm reading a book or I'm looking
through history and what could I learn
from that what did I do well what did I
what do I need to improve upon when I
think about the future I can't get lost
in it I could kind of think about where
I want my future to be okay so now what
do I need to do in the present moment in
order to achieve what I need in the
future and I think for me I didn't know
what I wanted because I didn't know what
found me happiness I didn't know what my
happy place was so I want some cool
competitions you know but it was never
enough but I still didn't win ADCC so in
my mind I'm like all right well maybe
it's it's I just need to win ADCC to be
happy no that's not it it's not it you
know it's never enough uh and that's
what I found it was never enough and
that's that that mentality of never rest
you know always do more and you should
never rest you should always do more but
that doesn't mean that you can't be
happy with what you're doing at the
given time you know and for me when I
realize all right what is success to you
or if success is happy to happiness
right my My Success is feeling happy
okay how do you find that you have to
find out what makes you
happy what made me happy was serving so
the more I realized that I would start I
I would I would find glimpses of current
you know I I remember I had a time one
time when I was younger I was in my
mother's living room and the breeze was
perfect it was the perfect temperature
uh I wasn't jumping out of my skin a lot
of times I can't rest like I always feel
like jumpy I was was completely
relaxed I wasn't cold I wasn't hot it
was the perfect moment to me that was
heaven right that was heaven right there
and and I wasn't thinking about anything
besides the breeze on my face the
current temperature which was perfect
and my current state of relaxation you
know and to me I was like well at this
moment I'm very successful no one knows
it's happening but no one needs to know
what's happening cuz I know what's
happening right and I think when you
first reach little bit of Fame in your
sport and you
realize how mean people could be it's uh
it's also a slap in the face because no
matter what you do people aren't it's
not good enough people always have
something to say people always want to
bring you down so when you're that's the
confusion you're living to serve people
all right well serving people and
helping people makes me happy but the
same people I'm trying to help and
serve have negative things to say here
and there how could you truly find
happiness well
the key was for me serving people the
best way I can being thankful that I
serve them and understanding how they
feel with me serving them is their own
personal choice I could only do my best
if it's not good enough for you I don't
know what to tell you because a lot of
people that you
serve over and over and over again the
first moment you don't give them exactly
what they want they forget every great
thing you've ever done for them them you
know and that's what they look at so
it's like you know what man I could only
do what I could do you know and that's
my best and I could take my past
experiences like the reason why I feel
I'm a great coach right now is not my my
victories but it's my defeats you know
you know what your students shouldn't do
through your past failures so when I
started realizing as well I could serve
people better by all my
failures the things that would break my
heart in the past were actually a
blessing without these failures how
would I serve other people how would I
know how to avoid the failures if I've
never felt them so I started to learn
more and more that you know success is
fleeting if you look at success as
victories because there's no such thing
as victories that last forever every
great Champion eventually Falls right
but what makes you
happy yeah that's what you're chasing
and it's it's pretty clear in the book
and you you mentioned it you know so you
you win the trials you go and do ADCC
you end up losing on like a mistake a
freaking clerical mistake which is
ridiculous oh man uh which then gets you
in the mindset of like all right well if
I can punch people we won't have any
clerical mistakes we'll have knocked out
teeth and victories you end up going
back to MMA you end up doing uh ring of
combat uh you fight three times in what
was it in the first year and and then
the next year so now we're into 2011 you
fight three more times and you're
basically just crushing people which is
I mean at this point the level that
you're at the school that you're at the
training that you're doing
like you're in a lower league you know
ring of combat at the time you're you're
above them yeah and it's it's show it's
proven out um you say by the end of 2011
I was offered the light heavyweight
title fight against Mike Stewart I
overwhelmed him the first round TKO
Victory uh they you get a title defense
against a guy named David what is it Tes
cavelli Tes cavelli oh man he was a
scary guy man and um that's a funny
story about him you you have this fight
Midway through the second round you feel
his energy change he was getting tired
and you basically go through this fight
and you you win um the funny thing is
going into that fight I looked him up
and it's a highlight video of like this
crazy Russian music he's from the
Republic of Georgia and he's just
suplexing everybody and then I see all
David teselli lifting weights he has a
54b plate he lifts it from it took him
like 13 minutes from the floor to the
sky pressing over his head he did it 250
times right I was like whatever I'll do
this right now so I went and I got a 45
lb plate and I'm like I'll do this right
now I got to like 27 and I was like oh
my God this guy's going to kill me I
can't do this but I was like you know
what lifting weights is not the same he
was the strongest man I've I've ever
faced but again as we were just speaking
about before there's a lot more to
martial arts and and to fighting than
just strength but uh he didn't suplex me
so that was a victory within it within
itself I mean that's what's and you do
talk about that in the book like you're
you're getting ready for the fight and
you know in your sort of from a coaching
perspective from a strategic perspective
you're always like okay you know if the
person's a better Grappler you keep them
on the feet if they're better on the
feet you take them to the ground if
they're better just you know you you
have this plan kind of General plan that
you're going to use as a as a fighter
but then you're like seeing his wrestle
is real good submission is real good
striking really good you're kind of like
damn but it's that is kind of crazy he
was that kind of level of conditioning
and you you broke him yeah and he never
felt stronger than me in the cage
actually uh I never felt his strength in
the cage I just think I had more
leverage and more smarts and I think a
huge aspect in martial arts and fighting
in Jiu-Jitsu is reaction time right so I
think timing is a huge difference
between average and great and great and
excellent uh a lot of times people know
the
technique but they don't understand the
timing and I and I explain it to people
have never wrestled before finding that
perfect time to shoot to take that
double it's almost impossible right and
a lot of times you don't have the
experience you see the shot but you
don't realize when you see the shot
that's when you have to
you can't see the shot and then think
about it uh so I I my timing was just
better than his you know he hesitated a
little bit and you know hesitation is
death you can't and that takes time and
experience but yeah I I was I I got
lucky man I I got lucky with that you
know he also traveled from across the
world uh fighting out of his country
it's not easy but yeah he was a strong
guy he was more strong than he was
Technical and you can't be that because
at the highest level everybody's strong
they freaks of nature
yeah and it's it's amazing you know you
take someone that even though someone
that can has this incredible aerobic and
anerobic conditioning to be able to do
whatever was 250 cleaning Jerks with a
50 lb plate like so he's got that level
you do 27 and you're already hurting but
the technique and the and the being able
to relax in the cage and not be tense
and not be like that's it another huge
piece and what makes people tense is
fainting and I always fainted a lot like
faints make people jump every time
people jump people get tired it's like
try to squeeze your hands together as
hard as you could see how long you could
do it eventually you're going to get
tired you know so um you know being
strategic in that approach and being
efficient efficiency is huge and I don't
think he knew efficiency efficiency he
went 100% a th000 miles per hour but the
thing is like you know I hate to bring
back uh we watch Blood Sport you know
when he said no hit back you know the
250 lb play didn't hit back you know
when you had that involved it gets a
little tricky that's what a lot of these
guys don't understand like these strong
guys I have no idea and you think this
day and age they would get the hint but
there's still guys out there that don't
train and they still just don't get it
they don't realize their strength is
it's cool it's cool to be strong God
bless you but don't mix don't be
confused yeah don't don't don't let that
get to your head a little
bit it's the same thing with you guys
and you know we have to also understand
like and and and here's here the problem
is like a lot of guys who don't train
who have weapons why you know my my my
gun will do it you know yeah I get that
right
but Jiu-Jitsu guys also need to
understand that in different scenarios
your ji- jits will only get you so far
yeah yeah like getting punched in the
freaking head yeah like you know like
that's and then after getting punched in
your head you know uh if I have a knife
in my hand that's also an issue right
like uh you know that's I see you know I
could equate this like I see a lot of uh
people get annoyed when JSU guys are
Fighters said you know it was a war or a
lot of Jiu-Jitsu guys when they call
their jiujitsu match a fight so here's
my thing uh no I don't believe a
Jiu-Jitsu match is a fight if you want
to say it I don't really care yeah I've
been punched in my face there's a huge
difference between getting punched in my
face and a Jiu-Jitsu match and at the
same time uh no I'm not dodging bullets
in an MMA fight right but I think m ma
fighting like when you look at the the
heart and the and the you look at
Frankie eder's fights right you can't
tell me that you couldn't put him in a
life and death situation and he wouldn't
fight with heart and honor right because
that's affirmative yes exactly you know
so that's how I look at that yeah it's
wild too um you know going back you go
back to like the the '90s the late 90s
and the early
2000s I would watch the UFC I was
training like I was training hard a lot
and you could watch the back then and be
like dude I could actually take this guy
in the UFC and be like oh I could take
this guy 100% and then and then I you
know I would got to train with those
guys and I like oh yeah I can take these
guys like I train with guys that were in
the UFC and be and know that I could
beat
them it's not like that anymore it's not
it's not like that anymore bro it's not
these guys that are these guys that are
and you know it it it went that way
pretty quick like soon I mean I would
say you know by the time this is what
2004 2005 you're starting to get real
like these guys are there's no holes in
their games anymore it's like what you
were saying about hey maybe the guy's
not good at striking cool I can stay on
the feed or the guy's not good at
grappling I'll take him down there's
nobody like that in the UFC and even the
guys who are like blue belts and
Jiu-Jitsu they're black belts about how
how to avoid submission and how to avoid
Jiu-Jitsu yes Jiu-Jitsu is so hard to
use in a five-minute match when you're
slipper so that's why I never went for
takedowns in my fight cuz if you go for
a takedown and you miss it it's just
exhausting then taking somebody down and
then they stand up again that's even
more exhausting like what am I doing
right now man these guys are good now
I'm so conditioned oh dude they're
Savages it's literally insane it's
freaking awesome uh what was the deal so
you write about in the book but talk us
through this uh situation that happened
with David's dad like after the
fight so it was actually his it was his
instructor okay uh he was in the Special
Forces for the the Georgian military and
uh man he gave me his dog tags and he
just said you know you fought with like
such heart and such honor and you
respected me and you respected David so
much like you know I I want you to have
this and
uh it it touched me so much you know I
still I keep in touch with his daughter
here and there like once in a blue moon
uh years down the line but yeah for him
to give me his dog tags after I beat his
fighter but you know it also showed me
like mentality of people from different
countries you know that you know it it
honor means so much to them nowadays
it's crazy when you look at these
Russian promotions every single way
there's a fist fight and stuff I don't
know what's going on over there but like
uh you know the I think the fact that
like um you know and I W I didn't cheer
too much and I raised his hand and I was
I was very thankful that he flew from
the Republic of Georgia to give me the
opportunity to win cuz without him I
couldn't have this big fight and he was
a champion over there and uh he you know
he was big over there like he was when
he would land like from wherever he was
flying from they would greet him at the
airport and everything he was a
superstar you know so I also understood
every time I won I understood somebody
lost so I know David had to go home uh
losing and in that
culture that could be really because all
they have in a lot of other countries is
their Victory or defeat you know you're
really only as good as your last fight
so I I I you know I had a lot of
compassion and and thankfulness for him
and I think his coach just saw that and
uh you know he I still have that dog tag
I'll never lose it man you know it was
incredible it was
crazy um going fast forward a little bit
here uh so now you're you're you're the
champion of that organization and all of
a sudden um you're sitting by the pool
one day and you get a call uh I'm go to
the book here Tommy did you hear me I
snap out of my thoughts to realize Ali
never stopped talking uh yeah just say
it again I'm saying it it has to be
tonight I need to call them back with a
yes or no to this you don't keep this
guy waiting listen tell them I'm on
vacation and the belt's not going
anywhere for a few weeks so they can the
belt no Tommy this isn't this isn't Roc
I'm talking about here we're talking
about the Big Show I lean up in my cheer
chair the ice pack slide off my foot cuz
you had it injured foot at the time and
falls to the ground practically sizzling
when it hits the hot surface wait what
you're not talking about Ring of combat
Tommy listen again Joe Silva expects a
call back in the next hour
if you say yes I got to get you on a
flight back home and get you back to the
gym my head is spinning now so the UFC
that Joe Silva yes that's the only Joe
Silva the UFC
Matchmaker and what's the match surel
debat am I saying that right yeah sural
sural debat I know his name I know the
name but only vaguely Striker European
of some sort it's finally happening I
look at my ankle more determined than
ever to heal it even if the UFC wants me
in a month I can make it work Tom
there's more he says and it's not good
they need you in Sweden Sweden that card
is in three weeks Tommy it's in 12
days I take a long pause understanding
that I am ultimately going to say yes
Ali knows this too but maybe for a brief
moment he thinks I might say no Tommy
this is it behind that sentence are a
100 unsaid implications when the UFC
calls you say yes if you don't they go
to the next name on the list and your
name may not come up next time at this
level MMA was filled with divas that
would play a 100 Mind Games to get a
better fight on a better card for more
money I wasn't one of those Divas but no
one knew that about me yet they didn't
know whether I was injured or just
looking for a way out or of a short
notice fight a hundred men would fill my
spot without a second thought if my
manager didn't pick up that phone and
say say yes within the hour okay olly
call him back and tell him to get me the
contract beautiful beautiful that's the
right call Tommy the right call how soon
can you be in my office I'll have the
contract ready for you just fax it to
the gym I'm going straight in mids
sentence I felt the sharp pain as I
stand up on my lounge chair and put my
weight on my ankle I take a sharp breath
12 days hey you okay Tommy you cut out
there just fax me the
contract yeah that was a rough one
because I was supposed to have a ring of
combat title fight the next month but I
fractured my ankle I threw a kick and I
hit somebody's elbow not my ankle my
foot and I broke the top of my foot like
the the little
bones uh and I was having trouble
walking and I was like fat out of shape
I was drinking
wine and and I accepted this fight and
they flew me out on Wednesday I fought
on Saturday and I had a training partner
who thought he was 64 so seral diabat is
66 and so I I trained with this guy so
much but he was like his frame was
small uh and he was not 6'4 I thought he
was you know cuz you thought you were 60
anyway yeah so when I got to Sweden and
I saw surreal I was like is this a 185
this is a 205 okay he looked like an NBA
player I was like my God 66 is he was
enormous you know the world class kick
boxer
and man like I just I had no confidence
because preparation builds confidence
and I didn't have preparation I don't
like doing things if I'm not prepared
I'm not one of those guys that call me
anytime and I'll fight that was never me
I'll never be that guy because I think
what happens a lot of times with that is
people call you to lose you know and
even if you put an exciting show uh you
you're still a winner there's a lot of
guys who could lose exciting and still
feel good my mental health wasn't that
if I lost I didn't feel good uh I didn't
know how to lose and I never lost an MMA
yet and man the fight was going good
until it wasn't you know I I won the
first round and the second round I I
remember you
know I took him down I was ins side
control and my corner was still like
screaming for me to get better position
to where I think it's very important
when you're a corner to and it depends
who you're going with like I I like to
stay remain calm in the corner as much
as possible but I started getting like I
started freaking out you know and and I
already had side control generally they
don't speak you up the stand you up from
side control but then like halfway
during the the round he like stood up I
I know I ended up on the bottom uh there
was one shot he hit me with with an
elbow but my head was against the canvas
so it had no room so I kind of got my
head smashed in between his elbow and
the canvas and he had a very large elbow
um and then he ended up winning a
majority decision it was a tough fight
it was a scrap uh one of the judges gave
it to me I don't think he should have to
be quite honest because I didn't really
do I took him down I positionally
dominated him I got like three takedowns
during the fight I passed his guard But
ultimately I didn't do any damage and he
did a lot of damage to me he uh he he he
hit me in the head a good few times he
can cuss me very well uh and that was a
that was a learning experience man
because going into that I was one of the
top prospects in the world and everybody
was such a Tom fan and then as soon as I
lost L it's like people forgot that I
took the fight on a week's notice that I
was clearly out of shape the weighing
pictures good if you're listening to
this go look at the way- pictures
they're embarrassing as hell I'm a soft
little chubby Dough Boy uh you know and
they don't care you know they think that
if you take the fight you should win
people don't understand like there's a
lot that goes into the preparation I
wasn't able to prepare so I took the
fight on short notice and people
ultimately were they were just terrible
they were they were just like ripping me
apart oh you got
tired yeah I got tired you know what I
mean like what do you think man like
come on give me a break here I I
definitely noticed in the book man and
even what you've been saying today like
and you write about it like that
gets to you like people talk and smack
about you bothers you it used to's
laughing because I that stuff people say
stuff about you know whatever read my
comments whatever like you know I think
Rogan has the best advice when it comes
to this stuff he's like just don't read
the comments post them ghost you you'll
hear him say like somebody that's kind
of like coming into the world he'll be
like no don't don't don't read the
comments you know he's really he's
really like serious about that and I can
tell you like I read comments I I don't
they don't they don't make me feel
anything you know I don't get mad or
anything and maybe it's because I'm not
you know this is very this is more
personal than I guess maybe what someone
might say about me well you definitely
take it more personally uh you're you're
in a fight and you lost and like this is
your career and people are talking smack
about you and you don't like it I wasn't
ready for it I wasn't ready and like and
I remember talking to Rashad Evans and
he's like you know one day we're doing
autographs and somebody walked up to me
and they handed me a picture of me being
knocked out by Leota machita to sign you
know damn dude and I just wasn't ready
yeah I wasn't ready for it at that time
that's the thing that these young
athletes got to understand I try to make
things very uncomfortable for them in
the training room right because when you
get out there it's not just competing
it's like you got to handle the bright
lights you got to and when I say bright
lights it's the pressure it's the trash
talk it's people who will never do it
that like to talk trash you know you
can't let that stuff phase you it got to
roll off you now I'm to a point I really
don't care it doesn't make a difference
to me like I realize I don't care when
my dad died and and somebody made like a
little cartoon right and it was like the
Simpson characters and it and one of the
Simpson characters was throwing a
Frisbee and there was no one catching
the Frisbee and the capture said Tom
playing frisbe with his dad and I
actually where where did you see this
they uh got tagged in Instagram and they
were like a burner account you know and
I actually I giggled a little bit I was
like you know what man you can't win
with these people so it it's like I
don't care anymore but at the time I did
care and and at the time it affected me
it affected my mental health and you got
to understand you can't care if you're
going to be in any kind of Limelight
whatsoever you just can't CU there's no
rules when you're in the when you're in
the Limelight like people forget all
about mental health people are like oh
don't bully this and that mental health
like no like
any kind of like anybody popular in
their field people are ruthless to them
they don't care what they say they think
they they look at these people almost as
if they're not people you know they're
not human beings I'll tell you one time
uh I forget what I posted about but I I
think I posted about a podcast or
something one of the podcasts
and someone put in the comments they
about Echo Charles and they were like
did just most
degrading comment about Echo Charles and
it was like hey who is this Echo Charles
guy and why is he on here everything he
says is stupid no one wants to hear from
him why is he on this podcast Joo you
shouldn't have him on and just talk
yourself and leave the echo guy out cuz
no one likes him it was something like
that and Ekko
responded he I said I like read the
comment was pretty pretty pretty harsh
and then I see a comment from Ekko and
it says honestly that's a fair
assessment and I was like that is the
best response it really is man you can't
go back out and you know what I've I
talked about on a podcast is like when
something bothers you there's it's
bothering you because there's some kind
of Truth in it and you know it's like
yeah Ekko is is going to say some stuff
on the podcast and like people there's
going to be some people that don't like
it and he say some dumb too by the
way no doubt about you know and so when
someone says hey what it's like someone
say about me like oh Jo's freaking all
dramatic about this like yeah well I do
get a little bit dramatic about some
you know what I mean like this is
like yeah it's true Jocko's a knuckle
dragger yeah I'm kind of a knuckle
dragger Jocko's freaking nationalistic
Patriot guy that just freak well yeah I
kind of am yeah I can get a little bit
blinded by you know patriotism like it's
all true like these things are true if
you let them when so when something
really bothers me it's like oh that's
cuz there's some level of Truth in it
and the best thing for me to do is be
like yeah that's a good point and same
thing you did you're like yeah that's a
good point cuz there's been times where
I've been talking about being on the
Baton Death March and reading from a
book of a guy that was on the Baton
Death March and what he suffered through
and Echo chimed in that like one time he
had to walk from the grocery store to
his car and the door wasn't open and he
had like a lot of bags with him and so
you got to be like yeah you know dude
you can't you can't really do that you
know so everyone's got their Vietnam
everyone's got their Vietnam you know
what it is for me though there's
actually something not too long ago that
I read uh they were just hating on me uh
they were hating on you they were hating
on goggin they were hating on uh a bunch
of and what what gets me is people who
have never accomplished anything right
or you being a man like being a grown
man how could you get behind a fake
screen name talk negative to another man
go home and look at your woman in the
eyes right like I don't get it it for me
but what I realiz I got to stop trying
to figure people out cuz you can figure
them out so for me like a lot of people
you know they think it's so corny these
inspirational things I mean I only think
people who think the inspirational
things are corny are the ones who have
never suffered right like they'll never
on like they've never been where you've
been you know like the reason why you
don't really care about what comments
say because how many times have you been
in life and death situations to where
like a comment is going to bother me you
know like you've been in some real stuff
uh and that's what I started thinking
like you know I you you just can't
change certain people and what I also
realize a lot of the hate that I've
gotten over the years uh a lot of people
who say negative things on my my post
right I'll go to their page and I'll
click on their messages they're guys who
used to message me that I never
responded to and they get their feelings
hurt I'm sorry that I can't respond to
every message you know what I mean but a
lot of people who hate they're just
people yeah sometimes they say things
that are true but they're also sometimes
people that are just very unhappy and we
remind them sometimes of everything that
they're not right so instead of looking
when I look at there there's a story
there's this guy walks by a house he
looks at the home it's like a mansion
and he looks at the home and he says wow
good whoever is living here good for
them they must have worked really hard
to get there like God bless them and
then the other person walks by and they
look at the house like go he probably
had this given to him his family comes
from money he's must be doing something
illegal which type of person are you
going to be you know and on the type of
person when I look at somebody I might
not agree with everything that somebody
says but I I try to learn if I can and I
just feel there's a there's a lot of
people who get behind a fake screen name
and talk and it's like for what I would
never comment on another dude's post for
no reason behind the fake screen name
talking trash you know and that's
it's just so odd to me it's it's odd and
it's also like completely common I mean
that's what the social media is yeah so
you can't get too hyped about that kind
of stuff it'll drive you insane you
can't you got to just kind of let that
stuff kind of roll you know what I just
I I wanted to uh so when you were
training with Ricardo
Alam and you were part of that school so
my buddy Seth Stone had got he went to
Princeton so he's in the SEAL Teams with
me he work with me and then he went to
Princeton and while and he trained with
me and he trained with me from like 2005
so now it's like I think it might have
been like
200 10
maybe but he's been training with me the
whole time I never give him any belt
because you know like you're not get a
belt for me I me like I guess I'm kind
of like you if you're not giving Gary
tonin his belt after he wins freaking
worlds so he goes out to uh Ricardo goes
to Princeton and he's at Princeton he
goes like hey where should I train I'm
like send me Google Earth like showing
me the map like who what's there see
Ricardo Al him like go go train with
there there so he starts training there
and after like a year he's like he's
like giving me reports he's not saying
anything but he's just like yeah I'm
doing good I I'm like getting some blue
belts and like I'm having good roles and
I'm like dude this this guy needs to get
his blue belt like this is not cool and
I wrote a letter and I sent my blue belt
my own personal blue belt from when I
was at blue belt and I sent a letter to
Ricardo Alam oh wow and I said hey I
want to tell you about this guy's past I
kind of talked about how he was in
combat and we were training the whole
time and he was traveling and like I
never promoted him and but I said like
if you think he's ready this is my blue
belt that I would like him to have Prett
intense and uh and he and Ricardo gave
him his blue belt and he read like that
letter to the class how incredible it
was freaking legit that's incredible but
you know that's one of those things
where that when I saw Alam like a year
later at some event or something like it
was pretty pretty legit just like the
connection between that he's such a
smart guy Ricardo like he's much
different than your typical uh Co
Brazilian coach that you would think
about like he's a very educated guy he
actually was accepted into one of the
the most prestigious schools in Brazil
uh to go to college and he didn't do it
and he chose Jiu-Jitsu instead very
educated guy uh
you could say how's he so educated and
chose Jiu-Jitsu
instead but he's such a stoic man you
know like I it's good because I had him
and I had hzo right so oh my gosh that's
chalk and I'm kind of like mixing ying
and yang that's why a lot of people with
me will be like oh you know like Tom is
very contradicting well no I am because
there's more than one side of me you
know there's a time where I'm serious
and you know more stalk and then there's
a time where I like to joke around and
there's a time where I feel people need
a hug and a time where I feel people
need to be smashed right like not
everything is the same every situation
requires a different me got to have you
got to wear many different hats it
doesn't mean you're fake it means you're
able to be a chameleon and you have to
be in order to make it mhm uh going back
into what's happening in your life at
this time so you get done with that
first fight short notice and now you get
another fight and this next fight is
going to be in China yeah thanks guys
thanks so much much how how much time
did they give you between those two
fights uh like two months I think oh
damn like I wasn't ready like I I had I
was severely concussed and now you're
going down to 185 185 and man like it
was in maau so I had to take a 17-hour
flight then a 3-hour ferry ride then an
hour taxi ride and I fought Ricky fakuda
who at the time he was like
24 victories and seven losses or
something like that uh tons of
experience and this was going to be my
seventh or e fight uh it was a scrap man
it was a war it was a good I don't want
to say War sorry it was a good fight it
was a it was a scrap uh but it was very
competitive but he ended up getting the
decision the majority decision again and
uh I was like you know what MMA is
stupid so stupid it's for immature
people I don't want to do this and waste
my time so I I was like I'm done I told
Joel Silva a lot of people were mistaken
about how that went I didn't officially
get cut by the UFC I I quit I I didn't
want to do it anymore and uh Joe was
cool he's like I I understand did he not
say like hey bro we gave you like some
pretty rough fights out of the gate just
I I don't know if he hated me or what
like it was very odd that the way it
happened but you know what though
man I'm thankful it did happen because
when I came up Glover Tara got signed at
the same time right if I would have won
my first fight 100% my second match
would have been against Glover and I'm
gonna be honest with you right now he's
a huge
205 I was a small
205 uh and when Glover hits you your
face breaks you know and I don't think
at that time I didn't have the he he had
Glover had a ton of experience like he
fought for years and years and years
before getting to the UFC I didn't have
much experience I fought for like a year
and a half then I got to the UFC I
wasn't ready like I was I was better
than like the local shows but I wasn't
quite ready for the big show you know my
timing was off uh and you know I lost
two tough fights and that was what it
was but then Bellator was fighting in
New Jersey and
uh Richard Chu reached out to my man I I
I stopped working with Ali and I started
working with Danny Lori again well he
thought I was still working with dannyel
Lor I wasn't working with Danny Lori yet
uh and uh he called so then I called Joe
Sila I said listen bellor wants me to
fight would I be able to fight for them
he says yeah you know I think you need
some more experience anyway so that's
that's a good thing so I signed with
Bellator and uh you know I ended up
fighting two times with Bellator two
victories uh it's funny experience to
talk about my first fight in Bellator
the first round I never lost a round on
my feet until this first round this kid
with a Golden Gloves boxer long lanky
dude Carlos Brooks uh he was chipping me
up man and he was getting so confident
he was doing like the Ali Shuffle and
everything I went back after the second
I kept trying to take him down Against
the Cage you know that was a whole game
plan and I I just wasn't able to do it
he clearly prepared for that so since I
lost those other two fights and I had
that experience I truly believe if I
didn't lose those two fights I would
have lost this one I went back in
between rounds and it's like it sounds
kind of silly but I was I said to myself
like there's no way I'm going to lose
this fight I just can't I can't lose you
got to find a way and I ended up taking
him down open cage I didn't go against
the cage you know what do they say
craziness is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
I was crazy the whole first round and I
didn't succeed so against the cage he
had no balance I mean in the middle of
the the kage you had no balance I took
him down with a single and uh I ended up
breaking his orbital I I hit him with an
overhand and and he was done uh and then
I had one more fight against Lambert and
that my fight against lamber my daughter
didn't want me to fight she was like
Daddy don't fight though and it started
it was like bothering me a little bit
you know I don't know why it was
bothering me too sensitive but uh it
bothered me a little bit and I ended up
knocking him out the first round you can
see that fight if you type in Tom the
Blaster is Jason Lambert as soon as I
knock him out I immediately go down and
I like check on him and I hug him and
dude I read that in the book and I was
like really like honestly I was like I
read that in the book and I was like cuz
it's it's written in the book like oh
you know felt like maybe you know this
guy has a kid and I was like you just
won the freaking I was like he's
exaggerating in the book like we're
going to see a like a little bit sure
enough man you knock him you knock him
out you knock him down and then he gets
back up a little bit and then you you
knock him down with one shot and as soon
as he's down like you you take like one
step back and look at him and then you
like legitimately I was like damn this
is exactly what you wrote In the book is
exactly what happened you it was it was
it's probably the most for lack of a
better word abnormal end a fight that
I've ever seen yeah you got to go watch
it go watch it it's like you can tell
there's a lot going on for you to be in
a fight anyone anyone in the world to be
in a fight and you knock a dude out and
then shut it off right away and just be
like I'm I'm not even happy about this
that's exactly what it looks like it was
it's it's very strange to say it was
strange you know and I remember Frankie
calling me afterwards like he's like
you're you're such a bull crapper that's
crap you didn't mean that he's like you
did it all for sure I like how could you
possibly do that for a show in that
moment you can't but I remember he was
his wife I remember he was talking about
his wife and his daughter and I was you
know I don't believe my mentality for
MMA was right at the time you know it
affected me I remember when I knocked
him out what came to my mind immediately
was I don't know how it flashed my mind
was if I was the one to get knocked out
and my daughter saw that how would she
feel uh so I felt bad immediately and
then I also realized like man if you're
feeling bad when you knock people out
maybe you shouldn't be fighting you know
like you can't feel bad uh and then I
had a match lined up against King Mo but
but I hurt my knee two times and I was
like you know what man there's a great
story I heard to where there was a flood
in a town and uh the guy went to the top
of the roof and a boat came to get him
and he said no no no don't worry
I don't need you here Jesus is going to
save
me water keeps filling up filling up a
helicopter comes to get him he says man
I already told the other guy I don't
need you here Jesus is going to come to
save Me So eventually the guy drowns he
dies and he gets to heaven and he looks
at Jesus and he says I thought you were
going to save me and Jesus says who do
you think sent you the boat in the
helicopter you know so I'm I'm getting
these signs and where they signs I'm not
sure but I just felt it wasn't my time
to fight anymore uh I don't think my
mentality was in it anymore anymore and
I and I hung it up and I I dedicated
everything to Jiu-Jitsu again so I came
back to Jiu-Jitsu I went to another ADCC
started competing in Jiu-Jitsu a lot
focusing on my school and uh that was
the best thing I ever did was to get to
stop fighting MMA because mentally uh it
wasn't conducive for me anymore it
started G like fighting started giving
me more anxiety to where you know just
the entire Lifestyle the way MMA is like
I remember training for a fight no
matter what I would be doing I would
never be able to enjoy the moment
because I knew there was a fight coming
I knew there was another human out there
training to to put me away and I I I I
was missing moments with my daughter
because I was focusing on a fight and I
didn't like that feeling I was and that
really contributed to the empty feeling
that I had within me because I was never
in any moment I was just I was I felt
like I was floating I was never able to
have a a so my my feet were never solid
in the ground because I was always
focusing on that fight hoping for a
victory and then I would win and then I
knew oh I know there's another fight and
that was kind of like King Mo was coming
up at that time right yeah yeah yeah he
was he he would have been a tough fight
for sure I trained with him uh I rolled
in here one day and Dean's like hey bro
uh my buddy's here we're training with
him and I go oh cool he's like you got
to go train with him he's a he's a like
Olympic level wrest he didn't make the
Olympics he came in second on the
Olympic trials right and I'm like oh
hell yeah and so I roll in there and
like we we clap hands and freaking he he
did a takeown with me like his face hit
me in the chest and His Hands just like
tapped the back of both my legs at the
same time with the force I'd not felt
before like Po like it all happened like
in a millisecond pop and I was on my ass
and I was on my ass like like six feet
away and I was like dude that's a that's
a freaking take down the was he was a
strong guy yeah and it was weird to
watch his career go the way it went um
he remember he ended up getting knocked
out by a guy with like some weird kind
of he he didn't use his wrestling a lot
he he was start he became a boxer and he
was a super nice guy and he was actually
as good as he was and his nickname King
Mo and stuff like he was super humble
always listen like ready to learn and
like great to train with uh I mean you
weren't going to get any takedowns on
this I'll tell you that like you you
going to be playing some some he wasn't
he wasn't very big either right like he
walked around like 210 right he probably
walked around at 210 he was not small
though bro WR and explosive and the
other thing that was crazy about him
like cuz you know he we would all
exchange you know techniques and stuff
but he he would talk about these like
takedowns and the couple things that he
would say is like he would be looking at
the ceiling on a takedown like he he'd
be like you got to look at the ceiling
like you your head has to be up but then
he would also just sit there and like
smash his face into the cage and grind
his face like putting pressure like
conditioning for his face and his head
oh my God cuz that's what he was going
to take you down with his his face and
and he took me down with his face many
times
like and uh and also super explosive
like when you do a cleaning jerk when
you watch an Olympic lifter do like and
they do like a a split squat as they do
the jerk like he would explain that
that's what he was doing he's like I'm
doing this like that explosiveness is
what I'm going into so and you're
telling me this and I'm saying to myself
like why the heck would I ever want to
fight this guy rubbing his face against
the I got time for
this uh but so you get a little bit more
focused on jit so I got to go to this
part of the book because it's pertinent
to the world you say right now I'm
enjoying laying a beating on an arrogant
prick of a purple belt he's fresh off
another win at a local Naga tournament
the kid wins everything GE or no gee it
doesn't matter he was bad enough in the
beginning as an arrogant white belt now
it's becoming apparent that he's
actually very good he's not just big and
strong he's smart he also works hard
shows up every day the full package he
walks into the gym with extra swagger
like a king returning from another
Victory he does everything but ask a
teammate to wash his car he even has a
cute girl on his arm bringing her to
witness the Victory lap and run circles
around some blue belts during practice
he's only been training a few years at
this point he has a lot to learn
technically sure but more as a man in a
weird way I really like the kid despite
all of our efforts to beat his attitude
out of him when he's a white belt he
just wouldn't eat the Humble Pie it's
the sort of pathological confidence you
develop a respect for over time you can
beat the out of this kid but you
can't beat the attitude out of him then
he starts getting really good now you
really have a problem ego backed up with
legitimate Talent while no one will say
it to his face everyone at Ocean County
Jiu-Jitsu knows that he's going to be
special and so does he I pair up with
him at the beginning and roll a fast
pace at this moment in time I am the
superior Grappler I'm a dog who's been
living on the streets he's a dog who's
been living inside side I throw him off
with my physicality forcing him to
Turtle Twist roll and shrimp his way
back into defensible positions all the
while I can't help but do a little
talking in his ear and yet I also feel
the kid is getting his composure back as
the minutes tick on he starts to write
the ship scoring a few minor victories
like getting his frames in by shifting
his weight to the side I bait him with a
faux submission submission attempt the
one I used last month on him this time
he ignores the Trap as his breathing
gets under control the veil that is
constantly over him has is briefly
lifted I see his face bright red with
sweat and frustration I see a kid that
needs to win a kid that doesn't
acknowledge losing like a normal person
I could beat him all day like this every
day it wouldn't matter he would just
keep coming back for more when we finish
out the role I'm surprisingly tired a
year from now he'll be as good as Gary 5
years from now who knows what the
ceiling is you know I own your ass right
I ask him he blinks rapidly and and
heaves out between big breaths if you
need to take a a break I can give you a
minute the stones on this kid I love it
this of course is Gordon Ryan the best
Grappler in the world my God that that
was literally exactly what happened and
there's a picture of that when that's
exact day when his girlfriend's sitting
on the side and I'm smashing him and I'm
smiling in the in the camera uh man
that's the thing that Gordon came up
like Jersey's a little different like
like our training is very hard noosed
and we're a bunch of people that all
think that's like the wrestling base in
there or something like that I think so
and we all came from backgrounds where
our fathers were a little
uh not that stable heavy-handed yeah you
know not stable and yeah Gordon was
something man he he was something
special and I I knew I you could even
ask him I I I always knew if he stood
with it did he start at your school no
he started with uh my my best friend has
hassim he gave his school to Gary so he
started with h and then Gary took over
the school that's where Gordon was
Gordon was never my student M always
like a little brother but he started at
15 yeah and he used to do like Kimbo
Slice fights like in his yard he used to
like do fights for money and he had like
a mohawk like he's just like fight yeah
fist fights yeah like a little
degenerate you know uh but he was just
the cockiest thing ever man it was and
and he was very annoying like I remember
one time he annoyed me so much I blocked
him on like every social media and he
was making like fake screen names and
still messaging me to like get his point
across and I'm just like you're so
terrible you know uh but yeah it came to
a point to where you almost had to start
respecting it because what the things
that people hate about Gordon are the
same exact things that make Gordon
Gordon you know he is he's someone that
I believe like when I say you know stay
in the moment uh be happy I don't think
he has that at all I think Gordon is
constantly out to prove something and I
think Gordon no matter how much he wins
he wants more so I don't know if he's
ever happy but at the same time it's
also making him and made him already at
his young age the best Grappler to ever
live and that's undeniable right so you
got to ask yourself are you willing the
fact that he's willing to have that
mindset for a long gated period of time
and like live this way indefinitely and
still get up every day and do it that's
a rarity yeah to be to get to the top of
the mountain and then keep climbing yes
is is uh rare very R and he's I mean
he's
winning easily look no easily very
easily it's I hate to use the word
easily but he's winning relatively
easily the best guys in the world and
he's still doing what got him there and
that's the hard thing to find most
people they get to the top and they're
like cool time to take a
breather and they that's why they don't
stay up there he just doesn't seem to
care I mean I know he's got some health
issues which is a which is a horrible he
seems to fight through him and yeah he
does he he gets he has this stomach
issue where he's just constantly
nauseous like always nauseous but it's
like there has been someone recently
that's been even close to challenging
him like we saw what he did to galow it
was just like it looked like a uh an
intermediate student against an expert
student it was just crazy yeah and just
for people that don't know Jiu-Jitsu
like Andre Galva was one of the greatest
competitors Andre is the most winningest
CCC champion in history and that looked
like a one-sided match it was it was
amazing they say his match with a lot of
people say Mason could give him a tough
time the only way Mason could give him a
tough time is if Mason stalls well and
then gets to overtime so ebi rules are
the only way in my opinion that you
could possibly be Gord maybe you could
hang on to his back longer than he hangs
on to yours I doubt it I doubt it but we
saw Nicki Rod at some success against
him in the ADCC I mean the ebi rule Set
uh which I never like the ebi rule said
I don't want someone to start on my back
unless they earn that right like uh so
many times you see people just get
mauled in regulation to go on to
overtime and win uh you know those boys
were actually winning in regulation and
in OT a lot of people now in that rule
set they stall in regulation and they
just make it to OT and then they they
find a way to win they get the double
under hooks on the back and they hold
longer so I I don't know man I don't see
I mean Yuri's is a very tough guy I's
match against Gordon and actually the
noi worlds uh the last noi worlds that
Gordon won the only one he competed
again it was it could have went to Yuri
it was super super close right Yuri is a
monster and I know Yuri wants this
Victory uh this is the next ADCC super
fight and that's going to take place
in August SE about
225 he got Gordon walking around it
right now about
220 dude Gordon's huge he looks much
bigger than he is like the last time I
saw him I was at UFC and i' I'd been
around him before at events but it was
like the first time he was like
recognized we like shook hands like hey
good to meet you but he's a freaking
large dude 63 every bit of 63 large Big
Frame he's a big dude man it's crazy so
people don't understand that he was I
can't believe he's only 220 yeah he's
not he's not I think the heaviest he
ever was like 235 and then he got sick
and he lost a bunch of weight but like
he won ADCC when he was 193 you know so
he's not just winning a lot of people
the haters will say it's because of
steroids no let me tell you something
let me tell you something everybody
listening your hero most likely is on
the juice right like everybody in ADC I
don't want to say everybody I'd say over
95% of people in ADCC are on something
and I will also tell you something it's
not making them win right their
technique is making them win the the
steroids are taking yes it helps them
but it's helping than the recover you
cannot train at a high level as a high
level athlete and and not supplement
with something it's very hard because
your body constantly gets broken down
over and over and over your testosterone
levels are actually lowering because
you're beating yourself into the ground
you know uh when I started trt I never
Juiced before and my testosterone levels
were at like 300 very low CU you're
training two so exercise can increase
your testosterone but over exercise
could actually reduce your testosterone
so I was training so much I actually I
was harming myself more than helping
myself you know so he's not winning
because of juice he's winning because
he's good man you know that's it no yeah
clearly I mean this the the technique
that he brings and you watch him it's
it's freaking
impressive he's he's impressive he's a
once in a lifetime athlete yeah I don't
think there's ever been an athlete in
any sport that has been as dominant as
he is in his sport mhm there hasn't I
mean I mean Tyson but not for as long as
Gordon was right Tyson until he lost to
Buster Douglas uh you know Mayweather
was dominant but May Mayweather wasn't
finishing people you know so I mean
Michael Jordan was something but it's
two totally different things the other
thing is he's he's stayed where he's at
through a large kind of uh
revolutionary progression in jiujitsu
Jiu-Jitsu is different now than it was
three years ago and different now than
it was 6 years ago absolutely and I mean
you could say I guess he's in some ways
leading that progression but like
there's people that are doing things
that three years ago weren't happening
like this was not a part of jiujitsu
jiujitsu is different now every and it
changes like almost I would say every
six months if you're not in the game
you're out of the game there's a
17-year-old who just won ADCC trials at
the at 142 pounds oh yeah that's right
he just ripped through everyone uh man
this kid was impressive his his tenacity
was something that people just don't
understand we understand because you
know a lot of people I always say people
start trying to pass the guard from the
feet until they can't pass the guard
from the feet and in about 30 seconds to
a minute they go to their knees this kid
won seven eight matches on his feet
passing the guard the entire time he
never went to his knees it was the
craziest thing that I've seen to keep
that mental fortitude that entire time
and then not have a a dent in your armor
it was truly something impressive like I
I was wow he's almost it's almost like
he's too young to understand that it
should have been harder yeah there's
it's like you know when you think of
chain wrestling when I think of chain
wrestling at the high level I think like
you're chain wrestling like seven eight
things are getting connected together
right like you're thinking about like a
guard passer like like him like a modern
guard passer the chain is like 29 yeah
things that are going on 29
things here and it's all these and you
make a fraction of a second over there
and another millisecond over there and
another millisecond over there and
finally you get a quarter second that
you need to get that knee through or
whatever that's what's going down it's
and what's crazy is what I saw him do so
many times he would be stopped so he
would do the same thing all over again
it's like he never had a a like most
people have a breaking point where like
you know they try it so many times that
eventually when they don't get it
they're like all right I don't got it
this kid man you could like I saw with
Ethan Ethan Krillin stopped him over and
over and over and over 30 seconds left
in the match he finally passed the
garden one he did something he doesn't
even realize how mentally tough he was
you know what it looks like it it almost
looks like he was he was made like he's
a machine bred just for this all he
knows is this you know he only knows
this what's his background he been
training in his whole life wrest he's a
purple bton Jitsu and a wrestler y he's
going to be special yeah there you
go uh going back to the book here at
this you say I H at this point I made
one of the best decisions I've ever made
I hired two people to run the operations
of the academy the first was my black
belt Craig ISO the second was a student
Danielle who had been training with us
for a while is that Danielle Kelly who
no no Danielle this uh Danielle Shelli
her name is she she actually uh my
current girlfriend uh we've been
together for a few years now uh man she
made things easy we talk about a woman's
touch
uh you know my school was successful
before her but my school wasn't I there
was a lot of things that weren't
happening you know like I would still
have like 17 to 20 delinquents a month
uh that means people aren't paying uh
and I just think in some aspects like
women just do things better than men uh
the things that'll kind of drive us
insane uh but when they do it for your
business it's actually nothing but great
and uh when I gave that aspect she she
initially started helping me uh during
like covid and we never dipped during
the pandemic we never lost students cuz
we were doing hardcore Zoom classes like
professionally Ram Zoom classes and uh
we had a woman's program before her but
it was never big and she started with
the women's program she she's built like
I I I tell her she's like she doesn't
like when I say she's like a Clydesdale
horse right she's just stacked yeah most
most girls aren't going to take that as
a big com she she she's a strong girl so
she ran the women's program and she
really started to build this women's
program and and I feel when schools have
large women programs that says something
positive for the school so all I was
doing the teaching of the advanced
classes she started doing all the behind
the scenes stuff and people got to
realize behind the scenes stuff is what
makes or breaks the Academy I ran the
school successfully a lot of it was just
my reputation but we took it to the next
level when she started doing everything
that we should do because for me I knew
a lot of the things we should do I just
didn't have I hate to say it and I have
the discipline to do it all the time
where she does right uh and the
organization the organizational skills
that she has uh you know she took over
everything she she started running she
does all my contracts for my my
affiliation and my contracts doesn't
it's not a the contract basically
consists if we split you just can't use
my name anymore that's it I don't want
to lock you if you don't want to be a
part of me I don't want I don't want you
a part of me you know but yeah she made
things a thousand times easier man you
know uh it it's interesting sometimes
you know like all couples you have your
your ups and your Downs so if we're
having some downs and we going to the
school you know uh I just stay in the
match he stays in the office and it
works out but uh yeah she does so well
it made things so much easier for me
yeah definitely a little bit of
decentralized command goes goes a long
way that's for sure um you end up doing
ADCC again 2014 2015 you win the ibjjf
noi Masters worlds
uh and you also did your weight and
absolute yeah never realized puts in
this perspective I competed in ADCC in
September at 217 in November I competed
I was 245 pounds it say that one more
time let let me cheack this yep 217 ADCC
in was that in September okay November I
compated at 2:45 damn yeah I went
through a little rough moment after you
got your grub on oh I sure did it wasn't
25 lbs of muscle there there's a picture
of me breathing out where my friend
would just always send randomly and it's
D like the photographer who took it
clearly must hate me cuz why you would
ever post this it's just I'm my hand is
kind of like like just limp and I'm
breathing out and my stomach is
protruding I won the absolute division
but I jumped in that thing and you know
do the master a vision it'll be easy
there are so many angry guys between 30
and 35 years old man that I I I was like
my what did I get myself into so uh yeah
I ended up winning I actually that photo
my my friend was sending it to me all
the time I was you know what I was like
I'm going to take this just fat shaming
you yeah you know I I made it before and
after I made it that was my before and I
made an after and I like kind of like
now he can't use it if anyone ever saw 8
Mile with Eminem the last rap battle he
everything you could say bad about
himself he says so the guy can't attack
him with it anymore so I was like I'm
putting my weakest moment out there for
everyone to see what could you do
anymore going to keep sending the
picture I already posted it I don't care
but it is quite an embarrassing photo
quite an embarrass what do you walk
around at normal now I'm like 213 214 uh
usually I was like 225 to 230 uh but 245
was heavy for me very heavy for me like
anything now above 220 for me I start to
get a little a little soft I got to 250
one time like it was a goal right and I
was like in a platoon and we were all
trying to be as big as you could be and
we're just deadlifting and squatting and
we were trying to get our average
platoon weight up above 200 lb and you
know you got some guys in the platoon
that are like 158 or something like this
right so they're going to put on 10 lbs
you know cuz they're hard gainers right
that's what it's called right hard
gainers so they can only put on 10 PBS
you know it's like hard for them so it's
it's it's on the rest of us yep to bring
it up so you know I was just eating and
deadlifting and squatting I finally I we
I was like 1 or sorry 2 like 47 or
something and I went on deployment in
the first place we went on deployment
was a place in Spain that had all you
can eat buffet for lunch and dinner Bo
and I was like I got this i got this so
I roll in there like four days and I get
to 250 and I was like oh cool 250 like I
helped out the platoon we're good and
then I went on a Four Mile Run oh boy
and I was like terrible and I was like
all right this is game over like I can't
do this this is just not good it's so
odd when when I I I went through moments
like that too where I thought I was big
and strong and like and then I look at
pictures I'm like you slob like why did
I think I was so muscular and I was I
was big but I there was so much
unhealthiness to that you know what I
mean like I don't know how you were at
250 I I actually think I just looked
like a little bit the same just a little
bit bigger all around know like I kind
of just like gained weight all walk 225
you're you're always a a big strong guy
some people handle it wear it well like
I I I could a lot of people don't think
I'm even 215 they think I'm lighter they
think I'm like 190 uh but I could handle
like 225 230 get above 230 it starts
getting a little yeah little mushy the
way I feel above like 230 I start to
feel like not good that's the thing like
when I travel when I'm heavy it's hard
man because all the walk to the airport
to travel the weight matters you know
it's like wearing a rucking vest right
like when you're when you're walking
around with a 25lb vest like you know
that's why so many people they're like a
lot of my my students like white belts
blue belts oh my knee is bad my back is
bad but sometimes it'll be 30 40 50
pounds overweight and like I I say to
them like listen don't get offended but
the first thing you should but the first
thing you should do for your knees and
your back is take off that 25lb weight
vest so I'm not wearing a weight vest no
are you know like you just don't realize
it you know and you do feel a lot better
when you're lighter man 100% y
uh this then you roll into uh BJJ
Fanatics which this is you know you tell
the story in the book but like BJJ
Fanatics is a website bjjfanatics.com um
it's run by a guy named Mike Zenga and
Bernardo far is a world champion like
great dudes and they made this website
that they have this vision of it
basically being like the Netflix of J
Jitsu yeah and they're very fair with
the instructors cuz they basically if
you're a Jiu-Jitsu name you can go on to
BJJ Fanatics and make instructional
videos about whatever it is that you're
good at you know you got some technique
that you're good at or some broad
strategy that you do or whatever
whatever's going to help people with
jiu-jitsu bjjfanatics.com they they made
this and you kind of you know you tell
the story that you they're like hey you
got to come to Boston to film and you're
kind of like dude I go to Boston to film
I'll just send you video you're kind of
like this is doesn't seem to make much
sense blah blah
blah and then a month later you get your
first check yeah that was a changing
moment in my life man that like that
gave me the ability to not be stressed
every month you know uh yeah they sent
me like a $40,000 check it was crazy
and you the thing is be what's really
crazy about that is like just so
everyone knows there's no money in
Jiu-Jitsu every Championship that we
just talked about you winning you didn't
get paid $1 you don't get for nothing
nothing maybe if you win
ADCC get like 40 Grand that's the
champion of the world that's with trials
you get nothing like your team thing you
get to Master's world's nothing no g m
no G world's not and you get nothing you
don't get anything from Jiu-Jitsu so you
can have a school and you know what is a
school a school as you just mentioned a
school means you're working 24 hours a
day basically and look we all love to
teach but it's you're working all the
time and you're gonna make money but
you're gonna get by it's more like get
by money so to get a check for 40 Grand
yeah for doing the Jiu-Jitsu that you
love for a month it's residual too right
like like I haven't made a DVD or an
instructional now in probably like two
years I I Zang is on my my ass about it
I really got to do it he'll be you yeah
but it's like uh it's still residual
income that I get every month right
because every month there's new people
en rolling jitsu every month that buy my
instructionals literally since I've made
my last instructional I think I made
like 13 or 14 my game has changed so
much I have to make another one uh it's
quite incredible it gave Jiu-Jitsu
athletes Financial Security the the
crazy thing is there's there's
well-known guys out there that don't
sell well they just don't sell well
right so you have to connect with your
audience so they let anyone film whoever
wants to film you want to film film
right but not everybody makes money so
it's like there's guys who have sold
three instructionals maybe to their
students and there's people who have an
audience that that bill like Gordon has
months where he makes 200 Grand you know
and it's just like the more popular you
are the more people relate to you the
more money you make so it's really
ultimately completely up to you and how
you connect with people right and uh it
it gave jiu guys the opportunity to make
money to be successful to not just make
money but to make good money to become
wealthy and actually uh it forces them
to remain disciplined in the social
media aspect right because you have to
connect if you don't connect you don't
sell and a lot of people hate social
media I I get it and there's a lot of
terrible aspects of social media but
there's a lot of incredible aspects of
social media social media has given a
lot of people the opportunity to be very
very successful I don't know whether
there's more positive or more negative
aspects of it but I choose to you know
look at the positive even my Instagram
my Explorer page all stuff that I like
to see it's not like I mean sometimes
there's some funny stuff that I like to
see right but uh you know yes sir I I I
I choose not to go on the the page where
if I'm looking to learn from somebody I
want to make sure I can put a face to
the name and I I want to know what that
person has done you know and I want to
be able to know the inspiration they're
giving is coming from a place of
experience I remember one there was a a
pretty popular men's uh page on
Instagram and I talked to the dude he
was 18 18 years old and I'm like brother
you're you're teaching men how to be men
you know like you you just started
shaving what's going on right now that
reminds me of Gary I remember one time
Gary was teaching and I had a I had a
student that was uh he made a few
million a year he was a very successful
guy and Gary after the Jutsu class was
like giving a speech to the class about
how they're all failures and this and
that I'm like Gary brother keep it to
jiu-jitsu man you're just a kid you know
what I mean
relax
um so you know at this point you do
more instructionals you end up uh
getting into the New Jersey martial arts
hall of fame I didn't even know there
was one but you're in it that's for damn
sure uh 2016 ADCC US National Pro
Champion 2016 ADCC North American 99
plus trials Champion again 2017 fight to
win 2018 fight to win champion uh you
beat Rico Rodriguez in
um the the cassai pro super fight winner
so you got all kinds of all kinds of
good stuff going on and then of course
uh 2020
hits I'm I'm going to go to the book
here for
2020 my father getting sick wasn't
entirely a surprise to me there were
early signs before my own run with Co
running with covid started in Earnest
before before I was hospitalized I gave
my father enough medicine for a small
army vitamin C D supplements
antioxidants everything I had living in
the same house you can try to be careful
but you can only do so much we knew he
could get sick if I got sick I told him
to be safe and be smart he didn't either
then again I'm not sure if I was being
safe or smart myself training in a gym
every night with hundreds of students he
didn't take anything I gave him even
after he went from sick to very sick he
was from a different time a time when
you just gutted everything out while all
his ailments addictions and being over
65 on top of that the disease worked its
way through him with very little
resistance even a medical team working
around the clock would have had their
work cut out for him for them by the
time he was admitted to a hospital he
was clinging to life just as with me
there would be no
visits after the fact fast forward a
little bit after about a week I walked
into my mother in the kitchen she held a
phone to her ear and was nodding to a
voice on the other side tears were in
her eyes as she kept nodding to a person
that obviously couldn't see her I knew
as soon as I saw her what she was being
told but she said the two words that
confirmed it how
long the curse of modern medicine is how
long it can Keep Us Alive well after we
should be 50 years ago my father would
would have passed away in a week now the
days ticked on he spent a week in
hospice then a week and a half then two
weeks he was more or less asleep at this
time his waking moments never going
Beyond a basic sort of awareness of the
room and its
occupants I was told I could finally
come and visit the old man they said he
was very close to leaving us but
admitted that he had far outlasted any
of their original
predictions if they ever give you the
opportunity to say goodbye to a loved
one think carefully about it often the
last thing you see is the most enduring
memory a human has gone two weeks
without food doesn't look like a human
anymore when I entered the room with my
father I thought I had I thought I had
entered the wrong room for a couple of
seconds he was like a skeleton reduced
to the bare minimum of muscle mass and
body composition I remember his chin
bone sticking out maybe a full inch from
his lips and odd detail that stuck with
me his his eyes were merely rolled to
different sides and he likely hadn't
used them for days despite their being
open half his hair had fallen out and
his body looks like parts of it were
literally missing he was covered in a
large robe and I thank God I didn't have
to see what his body looked like
underneath I will never forget that
image I spoke to my father starting at
around 5 in the afternoon we spoke until
the sunset we spoke into the night we
spoke long after most of the nurses and
doctors had gone home for the night
through the shift changes and check-ins
he could only groan and moan but he
often did this in response to things I
said it was clear he was aware and
listening at least on some
level the only message I wanted to
convey was that it was okay for him to
let go stop being so stubborn and let
this world go I told him that I loved
him that we would he would always be my
best friend I forgave him for all the
things he ever ever did to me I said
that I would take care of Mom and take
care of his
grandkids and I'll close out the book
with this
here I think about the reality that I am
with him now on the last Light night of
his
life I may very well see his life slip
away in the next hour or even
minutes I have a realization that
speaking to my dad is as much for my
benefit as
his it fends off the dark thoughts like
a torch in the
night all his darkness and all his love
have resulted in a strange mixture that
was me it reminded me of oil and water
that naturally separate in the bottle my
father had done terrible things to me
yet he also loved me with all his heart
and wanted nothing more than to take
back all those things the oil should
have corrupted the water but somehow
they both remained and I had taken from
each of them to become who I
am you showed up I whispered to him
maybe not every day maybe not for every
important moment but you're showing up
now for the last few years and we're all
grateful I felt like I saw the slightest
Twitch in his
eyes that that's pretty that's pretty
much it but one one thing I didn't put
in the
book is uh excuse
me I I had Co I didn't know I had Co my
dad was a very very good grandfather to
my kids uh he loved them and they adored
him but he would not out and I knew why
he was nodding out I knew he was doing
something besides just the methadone you
know and then I looked over one day and
I said that you cannot get high in front
of my kids like we just can't have this
you know and I looked over one day and
uh he nodded out and he was sleeping on
my daughter it wasn't like a sleep like
where he was just tired he nodded out
and I and I got Furious you know I I
pulled him
upstairs and
uh I didn't know I had Co I had a gun
and I'm like it it got very emotional
I'm like is this what you want and I put
the gun in my mouth and then
uh he's like no no no and then I I put
the gun by him uh I didn't know I had Co
right
and whatever we got over like our
million other fights that we got over
but I was very very disappointed in him
and he went to apologize to me the next
day halfway when he was walking
in he literally fell
asleep in the middle of the room like he
was walking and he stopped and he just
nodded out in the middle of the room and
I was like man there's no this just
there's I'm fighting a lifetime to make
this guy okay and he'll just never
change so I heard him
cough and I was like man I I I lost it I
was like you have Co I was like you have
Co cuz I found out I had Co like two
days later he's like no no no I'll be
okay I'll be okay uh I
got this one my uh I was out of the
house and my house wasn't built yet so I
was getting my
my smaller house built next to their
house at the time but uh I was living in
my old room for a few months and
uh I got really sick I was going through
a lot of stress and finally I started
like vomiting blood and I I just wasn't
well and uh I went to the hospital I had
to go to the hospital I forgot
everything I lost my memory in the
hospital I didn't even know why I was
there it was so odd soir i' never
experienced anything like this uh that's
like with Co I was always like yeah I
believe CO's real there's seems like
there's people on one side or the other
like oh CO's fake or oh co you know you
want Grandma to die no I believe CO's
real but I never believe we should be
shut down right that's just my attitude
about it it's another thing but uh by
the time I got out of the hospital he
was in the hospital you know and my
dad's on
methadone they didn't give
him uh his Methadone for the first two
or three days which you can't do that
you know and he was on 80 Mill gam of
methadone a day ever since that he was
just completely like non-verbal he was
very much able to like look at you and
make eye contact with you and um I was
actually able to go for a little longer
than I did I just didn't have the balls
to do it so finally when I went uh yeah
everything I said like he I I saw the
fear in his eye you know the fear in his
eyes like he was very my dad was always
afraid of death because he actually did
die and get brought back before and when
he
died that he told me the one time he
what he saw his dream when he died was
um a bunch of men with like melted faces
just walking around aimlessly like just
moaning were nowhere to go no end to it
I gather that's Hell whatever you you
know assume hell to be uh he told the
priest that before and the priest just
told him to pray pray pray uh well I
know my father worried is that's what
are you going to see that again but I
know for a fact if there's a thing such
as heaven or hell my dad earned his spot
uh he was in I just wanted my father to
just forget about all the times he's
hurt me and just focused on his
grandkids and just be happy because he's
an amazing grandparent to my my children
and my daughter is still is heartbroken
over his loss over his death and uh I
said don't worry like you could go like
you know you're suffering now but the
suffering is going to be not that much
longer I have to had to on me Suffer
Well you know I said you know you lived
a certain life and now was your time
maybe he was on hospice for 16 days uh
which is a long time on hospice you know
and
uh I I don't
believe like I felt my father's presence
Heavy after he passed away and the way
he died since I'm the one who gave him
covid it was very ironic in the sense
that I only wanted him to be okay my
entire life and then I'm the one who
actually gave him Co and the way I gave
him Co was through an aggressive
argument uh so it was just very terrible
it was very very hard for me to deal
with I I I carried the weight of that
burden like my whole life I just wanted
him okay but then I realized like I'm
the one who helped to put him out of his
misery the only peace for my father was
in death for sure and my mother she
would have died for sure of a nervous
breakdown she was still working you know
she was you know much she was out of
shape overweight very depressed anxiety
stricken I actually chose to go back
there rather than get another place
because my mom was taking him to the
methano clinic every day before work so
she would drive 30 minutes to the clinic
30 minutes back home 40 minutes to work
work all day get home by 6:00 at night
be up at 4: in the morning for the next
day so I said you know I'll start taking
D so I started taking him
and uh you know here I am me few years
ago driving my dad back and forth to the
methodone Clinic you know not not
everything is always what it seems and
I'm pretty known for being pretty
transparent on social media about my
past and about my life and my my
shortcomings and my struggle mental
health and stuff uh but I felt so bad
for you know ultimately killing him you
know and people say oh no you didn't
kill him well no let's call it sped of
spade I did and it is what it is it just
is what it is and uh
but in his death he was given peace and
I believe life and my mother was given
another life she went through a really
hard time for like 6 months to a year
and now my mom is happier than she's
ever been I I got her to retire early
you know I take care of her she helps me
with my kids uh she she needs me with
the house like she lives it's my home
but she lives there of course I live in
the smaller the smaller uh section it's
like six feet from each
other uh I take care of everything just
got them my mom never had central air or
nothing I just got her central air I'm
able to do a lot of nice things for her
you know uh and and I'm thankful to do
that so sometimes through
tragedy it's tragic at the time but
sometimes we don't always understand why
things are the way they are we don't
always things don't always go the way we
want them to go but sometimes they go
the way we need them to go you know so
my dad was in my dreams for a long time
you know I felt him for a long time and
and I basically said like man like I
can't have you here you know like I
can't have you in my dreams I I don't
want to really think about you I don't
want to really the only time I'll talk
to my dad is when I ask him to help my
kids and to watch over my kids uh
because I can't live with him in thought
I still have a lot more to do because
that paralyzes me you know it makes me
it affects my mood even now when I'm
talking about it I'm not letting myself
get attached to the conversation I'm
talking about it from I'm cutting my
myself out of the equation I'm like I'm
almost like I'm talking about a movie
that I've seen I'm not putting myself in
the equation because I can't let myself
get emotionally invested because when I
let myself get emotionally invested it
weighs heavily on me and when it weighs
heavily on me I I'm
very me when
I'm depressed or or feeling bad is it's
dangerous not just for me but for for
for other people you know like if I get
cut off on the road or something like
that something that should never even
bother me something that's just so
minimal that could that could actually
really affect me because I'm being
emotional and anytime a man has run on
his emotion he's basically an overgrown
infant you know that's what it comes
down to I always tell my students you
cannot be emotional you have to be
strategic you can't the moment you're
emotional you lose everything you know
uh and I do get emotional when it came
to him so uh yeah I haven't I don't
really like waste time thinking about
him because I do believe we'll be
together again and it's life is crazy
man like I was laying with my daughter
the other day and it's like one day
she's going to go through everything
that I went through you know and it's
just the time I'm here I just need to
make sure I I get them ready for my My
Soul Purpose with my kids is I want them
happy and I want them healthy but I want
to get them them ready to live where
they don't need me that's it right once
I know my kids don't need me I'm at
peace and that's all I need I need I I
need more time with them to to to get
them ready for the world because the
world is cold the world is brutal as we
know and they'll never experience the
pain that I felt but at the same time
that's also a scary thing right because
what makes us us it's our pain but we
don't want our kids to feel that pain so
how do we have our kids you're doing a
good job right obviously that's success
right there when your child could grow
and be successful and be happy no matter
what you do in the world no matter you
jao being jao if your
daughter struggle tremendously it's very
hard to find true peace and happiness
you know be awful but the fact that you
could walk on the mats and train with
her and be with her and she's your best
friend and to have that relationship
with my daughter you know to where she
wants to be around me and a lot of
people would think I'm that Dad that's
like hard nose and don't do this no I I
want to know you Isabelle I want to know
your problems I want to know what you're
going through uh and I want you to
understand everything I say to you it's
for you it's not for me you know so I
learned a lot I'm so thankful for my
father I learned a lot about how to be a
man but also how not to be a man through
him you know so ultimately life is a
trip man it's it's it's quite insane but
uh yeah it's I didn't do the book
Justice today because the way the book
is written it's actually you it's the
the setting of the book is you and your
you're driving your dad to the methodo
critic and it's day after day after day
and you're you're telling him your life
story the parts that he's missed
so yeah I could it would be weird I
would have just had to read like the
audio book if I was going to do that
right so get the book everybody um
there's so many lessons that we didn't
talk about today um and then you're
still doing all kinds of other stuff but
buddies over bullies yeah or.org buddies
over bullies. org how did that get
started did that get started when
somebody sent you like a bullying uh
social media thing this girl was getting
viciously attacked on the bus by some
older boys and I was like man like this
is just horrendous so I said if someone
find me this girl and they found me her
parents or her mom so I was able to talk
to her mom when I got this girl training
in a local martial arts school so what
what it is
basically I the 503 is just about to be
up and running and set it happen all so
fast everything happened so in the
beginning it's just like all right kids
in my area who are bullied who can't
quite afford Jiu-Jitsu I give them free
training I sponsor them training uh kids
around the country or the world if I so
I'll post a video hey help me find this
this is the beauty of social media right
how could I find these kids without
social media within 6 hours of posting
these kids I'm able to get in touch with
their parents and then then I'm able to
reach out to them talk to a local school
school owner reach out to the school
owner get that kid involved that that
school cannot afford to give that kid
six months free training we'll sponsor
that right if they can't afford we're
very thankful they're taking on that I
post them I talk about them I I you know
I give them a little bit of Limelight
not that they're doing it for that
reason but they deserve it right because
they deserve it because they're
inspiring other people to do it and uh
it's helped so many kids uh because it's
giving them the benefits of Martial Arts
but not only learning how to defend
themselves it's giving them a community
and helping it's helping them to see
like they are loved there is people who
accept them no matter like a mother I
don't there was a video of a little
there's a teenage boy he he loves
Spider-Man and a bunch of kids tricked
him and said oh yeah we're goingon to
we're going to dress up as superheroes
come come to the park dress as
Spider-Man he came to spider he came to
the park all excited to dress as
Spider-Man and everybody just pointed
and laughed at him and a girl went and
she smashed his face in and broke his
knows right haha so funny like where do
you find the pleasure in this like oh
hurt people hurt people I don't
understand that a lot of people say oh
but you know you should help the bullies
I'm not there emotionally yet to want to
help bullies I don't like them because I
suffered a lot that never made me want
to make other people feel bad how you
could hurt an innocent person is beyond
me my bullying stopped is when I took a
rock and I bashed in his ear that's when
it stopped no amount of talking and
begging stopped him so I talked to the
mother the other day uh and that kid's
doing fantastic now he's doing his first
competition it's so great to hear that
they're doing so much better and they
have a new community they realize that's
I just got to say this that's a that's
changing a human being's life yes that's
changing a human being's life yes and
they're realizing like man like the the
problem is in school like school is such
a small part of a child's life but it's
all they know so if they just realize
like listen these idiots in school who
are bullying you you're going to be
around them a few years but there's a
whole another group of people that love
and appreciate you that you have that
you could rely on and they're getting
that through this organization and it's
just an amazing incredible thing you
know and and I'm so that is my purpose
for sure to help these kids like I found
my reason my why is to help these kids
you know and it's a it's a beautiful
thing man yeah well I I I guess I almost
get made fun of at some points because
when people tell me what kind of
problems they're going through in life
I'm always like oh you know step one
start training Jiu-Jitsu like someone
just asked us a question the other day
and he's like and you know you don't
need to tell me to train Jiu-Jitsu
because I'm already training Jiu-Jitsu
but with kids like all the time you know
get the kid people ask me kid's getting
bullied kids's getting picked on kid
doesn't have confidence kid is
overconfident like all those problems
that kids have yep train jiujitsu TR
jiujitsu TR ji- Jitsu TR jiujitsu so the
fact that you've taken it it upon
yourself and this organization to set up
to to get kids to train Jiu-Jitsu is
just it's just outstanding and like that
one story you just told about that kid
that's now training Jiu-Jitsu that's
doing his first competition his entire
life is on a different trajectory now an
infinitely better trajectory completely
so doing that over and over again is
just going to be it's going to have an
impact all over the place and so if
people want to support that buddies over
bullies. org that's where they go yeah
reach out to me on uh on Instagram uh
you know if you have a problem you know
if if you know a child who's being
bullied do your best right attention
I'll do my best to get to it just bear
with me because right now it's only me
working for it that uh is trying to do
all that I could do and there's a lot of
other things that I'm juggling as well
and as far as Jiu-Jitsu even if you're
not a Jiu-Jitsu guy or girl listening to
this which you probably are you got to
understand you know there's certain
instructors out there oh Jiu-Jitsu is
not for everyone that that's crap man
Jiu-Jitsu truly is for everyone you
could be a middle-aged mom what what are
you looking for for for a goal setting
weight loss self-defense competition
friendship uh you you just are faced
with adversity on the mats in a positive
way right to where you will become a
better husband a better wife a better
brother a better sister a better friend
you're just becoming a better human
being overall and like here's the thing
when I first started Jiu-Jitsu I just
wanted to compete compete compete I
don't even I can't even train hard
anymore because I I need new shoulders
but I find a new love in teaching you
know your your goals change as you grow
right so you will find you know your
Niche and Jiu-Jitsu and and and why is
it called Niche or Niche Niche N I think
that's the first time I've ever said
Niche the correct way well we got it
documented here big time for for a long
time guys the funny thing is one thing
I'll say I was saying for a long time I
was saying you know you do this it's
going to come into Fruit instead of
fruition right and I was standing in my
students for like six months and none of
my students had the balls of it's not
fation it's fruition yeah so here we go
something new what you just said about
like you just use for everybody and
like with with with a family your family
should do Jiu-Jitsu look I'm going to
say it like you you met you just met one
of my daughters I got four kids all my
kids do Jiu-Jitsu or wrestle or train
they all do it my wife trains like she
doesn't train much anymore she had four
kids she was pretty busy but she trained
hardcore back in back in the day I mean
and guess what when like when we talk we
can talk about jiujitsu it's a common
in the family of like how was your
training did you train today what did
you train what you learn what did you
work on what about this Mo and by the
way when like I send a meme to my family
about like oh you know oh you don't want
to date this guy we just saw him pull
guard or whatever like the whole family
gets it right there's a common theme
there so yeah and and you can talk about
it and you can do it you can train and
there's so many different aspects of it
like one of my good friends now we we we
developed a relationship uh he went to
one of my Affiliates uh he thought it
was my school and it was my affiliate in
in Kentucky Tom Hardy and the crazy
thing is my best friend who was you know
he wrote him he was in in he was a one
perer he just died Tom Hardy was filming
the film the bike riders is about the
first one perent it was so crazy The
Coincidence but uh he's obsessed with
jiu-jitsu obsessed with jiu-jitsu uh he
finds so many parallels between
Jiu-Jitsu and life and Jiu-Jitsu and
acting and it's like when you could get
people that are very successful in their
own right being obsessed with jiu-jitsu
and they feel that it could help them
become a better person how could anyone
say that it can't help them right it's
just there's so many aspects to it man
that just make you a better human there
really is and you just have to
understand like there there's two things
some people say you could have no ego
but at the same time your ego could also
help you if your ego could help you get
back to class the next day after you
have have a tough day your ego can't
help you from not you don't want it to
make it get your arm broke right uh you
got to understand in training there's no
winning or losing in training there's
just learning in training but for me the
reason one of the reasons I I continue
to show up on the match every day is my
ego I refuse to not show up because I
know there's other people that are
showing up my ego gets me there you got
to stay on that bus stay on that bus man
the bus is moving if you get off the bus
bro it's going down the you know it's
going to bring us up when we when you
were mentioned in social media there's
good aspects and there's bad aspects and
somebody asked me a question about this
as a matter of fact at the camp somebody
asked me about like what about with
social media is it good or bad and I
said it's like fire right fire can heat
your house it's good it can burn it down
social media you can connect you can
help bullies you can save people you
connect with people or you can freaking
waste your life um same thing with ego
like yeah can your ego be out of control
and now your ego can be so big that you
don't get on the map yeah or your ego
can be so big that you get your arm
broken for no reason so you don't want
to go to that extreme your ego can also
be so small that you don't have the
confidence to go on the map correct so
everything happy medium yeah you all the
time you got to you got to find that
balance um you recently came out of
retirement uh I think it was this
weekend you came out of retirement had
another fight right man that was
incredible freaking cool that was one of
the coolest things I've seen man I saw
that on the internet as well it was a a
man with Down syndrome and he has
Alzheimer's okay and he was talking to a
sister he said Jessica why why did Jesus
make me this way she said what do you
mean she why did he make me in in school
everyone will call me and she's
like I know but she's like Mary that was
years ago it goes yeah but I still
remember it and I just wanted to be a
wrestler but why did he have to make me
this way and I was like oh it broke my
heart and I was like you know what I'm
not a WWE wrestler but I am a Jiu-Jitsu
guy so let's give this guy a match you
know the funny thing is leading up into
this match I'm looking at his video and
he's like chest slapping and punching
and I told this his like listen you know
this is a grappling match right like I'm
not going to get hit with a chair over
my head so we went into the match
finally he he prepared he started you
did it you did it at a big event yeah
Men of War it's on a stage it's it's
it's a really great event it's a local
event excuse me
sorry and I I reach out to them I said
guys I want to give you this opportunity
to host this because it's going to bring
a lot of eyes to to your Arena as well
and
he trained for like two months with
black hole
Connecticut and they they did their best
to help him get ready and we did the
face off and apparently all he was
talking about was winning that belt and
he had a belt they got a belt prepare
for him so we went in the match he took
me down with a single I stood back up I
wanted him to work for it you know but
man he danced out to the ring and he was
ready when he finally tapped me I looked
up and his face was just he just stared
at me and I was like oh this isn't going
the way I expected it to go like he's
not excited and then immediately he just
put his hands over his face and started
crying and I started crying and the
problem was I didn't think I could stop
it I was like God get get it together
right now and like literally this was
the best night of this dude's life and
it took minimal effort all we had to do
was post about it and they show up and
give him the opportunity to do it you
know and it was just so incredible and
that's the power of social media right
it made me connect with him this dude
was a superstar I've never been so happy
to lose in my life you know it was
incredible yeah that was that was
amazing to watch uh to see to see you
pull that off and so then you also got
obviously got Ocean County BJJ that's
that's your your headquarters Academy
but then you have this affiliate program
where people what is it if I was one of
your Affiliates what would I get out of
that so basically you get to talk to me
I'm I'm talking in the group chat chat
we we have a big group chat that I'm in
every single day uh anything you need
you can reach out to me I get back to
you immediately um I don't force you to
wear my GES I don't force you to wear my
uniforms but you can include my logo uh
you can use it I don't force you to the
one of the beauties of opening your own
Jiu-Jitsu school is doing it the way you
want to do it right so I don't force you
to teach a certain curriculum but I do
allow you to come to my Academy see how
we do things ask how to do things and
you could do things the same exact way
as I do I I basically I give you the
choice you could use my Logos you could
use my name you could you you could
reach out to any of us and take what you
want and if you just want to say you're
part of the association and really not
use what we're using okay you could do
that as well I do recommend that you try
to take as much knowledge as you can I
don't give you a set curriculum because
what I charge a month is so cheap if I
were to just give you my entire
curriculum there's a two there's a few
things wrong with that number one you're
not thinking for yourself S I want you
to be a critical thinker I want you to
be your own person your your own School
owner number two if if I was to do that
I would have to charge significantly a
lot more money I charge my Affiliates
250 a month but I have some Affiliates
like one in Philippines it's a it's a
it's a charity affiliate uh they don't
pay at all I have another guy in South
Africa uh he's not paying yet because I
don't have enough students yet like I
never had an affiliation to make money
money is always a consequence I feel of
doing the right thing uh
we do have a lot of Affiliates now like
63 to 65 and every single person who's
in that affiliation could tell you like
I am at their becking call when they
need me I had one guy I love him to
death he was messaging me privately
every day and I said brother do me a
favor I said let's keep it in the
affiliate chat right because any
question that you have I'm sure
everybody also has right so it's hard
for me to speak to every single person
individually unless it's like a huge
problem I'll definitely make time for
them but I am in the group chat sharing
things showing things answering any
questions they have any technical
questions for sure do it um and they're
always able to come to my Academy and
visit and we have a lot of my
affiliations my affiliate student and
also any of their students could come to
my Academy and train for no mat fee as
much as they want how do you vet the
people that are going to be Affiliates
that's a good question so I basically
talk to them uh I want to know what
there there there's a series of
questions that they got to answer what
is their reason for Jiu-Jitsu what
lineage do they come from what happen
with your previous lineage uh are you in
trouble before uh I do got to start
doing background checks for sure uh I
haven't yet i' I've taken their word and
I haven't had any issues um but there
has been some people that I've turned
away that when they tried to come to me
they had a lot of negative things to say
about their previous affiliation and I
didn't think that it was solely the
affiliation fault I think usually
there's three ways three sides of every
story and if the person can't see their
issue at all most likely history will
repeat itself with me you know you can't
please everyone so there have been some
people I said hey you know I don't I
don't think so there have been some blue
belts that wanted to open under me I
said n you know not a blue belt yet
let's get your purple belt and then you
can kind of like get your foot in the
door uh preferably I i' want you to be a
higher belt of course uh black belt
preferably or you know brown belt I have
some brown belts and on their way to a a
black belt uh but I'm pretty cut and dry
like if you put the time in once you're
part of my affiliation if you show up
and I see you at my school and you've
been training for you know if you're
four years as a brown belt you're G to
get your black belt right like if you're
five years like I have a guy that I'm
going to be promoting to brown belt soon
he's in my affiliation he's been with me
for over a year trained to me like 10
times visited me already and he's been a
purple belt for six years you know so
he's going to get his brown belt U very
very soon so uh I'm a like I don't have
any contract with BJJ Fanatics it was
just a handshake nothing was ever
written so I'm that kind of guy still
maybe I need to to get out of that
Danielle's the one who made the
contracts for my affiliation cuz I never
had them I I I don't believe like I
don't know like if you tell me you're
going to do something I want to take
your word you're going to do it you know
but also at the same time it's a
different day and age you know so I do
feel I have a pretty good judge of
character when I talk to people so I do
I have direct contact with every single
person who wants to be an affiliate I
have to talk to them I have to hear them
I have to know what they and what I do
is I I have them download WhatsApp
because a lot of times on the on the
phone if you say something people forget
you say it I want everything a record of
everything everything you say you said
this at this time then I said this then
don't tell me I didn't say it I already
told you I learned that lesson a long
time ago so it's growing significantly
all the time yeah so if people want to
get to that it's uh tomthe blast.com and
you can get all the stuff and you do
seminars you got the book obviously um
what else does that get us up to speed
with what we got going on the Tom to
blast world I announced for 1 FC I
announced her grappling matches uh oh
that's right that's right we just
speaking to Danielle Kelly I was
listening to you uh announced her
freaking awesome win that was a great
win man she played the R so well oh yeah
that's what people I talked to Jessa
before the match and she's like I was
like did you start working the cage yet
she's like I'll do it closer to the
match and it was two weeks away from the
comp I was like what do you mean closer
to them I should have been doing this
for two months already you know but yeah
Danielle plays that Ru set really really
well man Danielle the I think it was the
match before the girl was trying to do
the can opener T her and Danielle just
like starts working you see her hips
start to move her hips start to move in
next thing you know she freaking goes to
the girl's back and I was like hell yeah
Danielle Kelly get some she's freaking
out standing uh so you're doing that um
what else anything else anything else we
need to know about no I think that's it
you know if you guys need me find me uh
you could actually just email me at Tom
the blast at gmail if you if you're
interested in the affiliation just put
affiliation and capital letters my name
at gmail easy enough and uh yeah that's
it man I really appreciate you you
having me here yeah man I mean just so
everyone knows you're on the interwebs
uh oceancounty BJJ dcom is your is your
school uh Tom theblast.com leads to a
bunch of this stuff buddies over
bullies. org I think this is a freaking
outstanding
organization uh you're on Instagram and
you're on Instagram too like you don't
you don't post and go bro you post and
get in there you're ready to scrap bro
you're ready get in the game with Tom I
said about like the no don't get don't
read the comments Tom to blast be
reading the comments and not only that I
I calmed down significantly after the
pandemic I was like heav like people say
they're Shadow band no no no you
couldn't even search my name for nine
months right like you couldn't find me
for nine months I went to like uh you
know like 10 million reach a month to
like 20,000 right because I was I was
going hard at people bro like now I
don't do that anymore I I can't you know
I can't because you know what is people
perfect example somebody said something
to me like I during the pandemic like I
hope your kids get Co and die right and
I went hard on this person the person
deleted their comment and screenshotted
what I wrote they posted on the internet
like I just went at him for no reason
for no reason oh this is the true Tom
the blast come on bro so you know you
can't get people did you threaten their
lives what did you do I I BR I've gotten
people's IP addresses I I've oh you're
going that I've doxed people before I've
done crazy stuff but like but I didn't
realize but like one guy was ripping my
DVDs he was he was pirating my DVDs and
this is a few years ago so I found out I
got guys that could like they find crazy
stuff like my some of my friends and uh
I posted like his his his full name I'm
like if you're going to steal from me
people should know who you are right was
that was looked so down upon that I I I
I doxed him I didn't know anything about
that but so many people were offending
like he's stealing from me but I'm wrong
for doxing him Echo what's your judgment
on like okay if somebody steals from you
so this guy stole from Tom yeah and he
doxed him yeah so what is docks exactly
I thought you were like a pro this
that's when you say on the internet like
hey there's this person's name and
address oh yeah yeah cuz they stole from
me that's doxing and it's the thing is
it's really like a big deal in the world
and what's weird about it it's a big
deal because it's taking the virtual
world and bringing it into reality it
makes the whole everybody that's a
talker on the gram or whever else it's
like they that's like a a huge violation
it'd be like if we're doing Jiu-Jitsu
and I start punching you right it's like
that type of thing but here's the thing
what did that person do that's that
they're getting punched now right like
it's like there has to be consequence
yeah yeah I guess right
for stealing from you and then there I
guess there's a bunch of levels of
stealing right so the they pirated your
stuff yeah it well the way I see it yeah
if you steal from someone and they dox
you hey that's the way the world works
you want better would you rather me go
to your house and drag you out or would
just me write your you know dox you now
here's the thing I always I'm known for
all the time I get my school address
like now when people talk trash I'm just
like 336 La I seen you do this I was
going to bring that up when we were
talking about the comments someone will
be like I'll beat your ass you're like
here's my address where you send
location let's do it let's do it you
know and and I always say now I'm very
kind like listen if you want to come and
talk we could talk if you want to come
and fight we could fight whatever you
want to do we could do you know and it
just you can't win with these people so
I don't dox people anymore I really
don't get into it anymore uh I don't
look I didn't look for the IP addresses
anymore like I didn't look for the IP
address to the guy who made who threw
the Frisbee with my my dead dad I'd let
him go for now for now uh so there you
are you're on Instagram you're you have
Twitter I haven't I looked at your
Twitter account I I don't post on
Twitter I there's like somebody who has
my name on Twitter but it's not me I'm
on threads that Instagram one uh and
you're at Tom the blast Jiu-Jitsu as
well um on YouTube so you got a little
YouTube channel yeah I don't post there
either best thing is Instagram Instagram
and threads I'll check threads every
once in a while Instagram I'm always on
always so that's where Tom de blast is
at Echo Charles you got any questions
um is it a question yeah oh okay yeah
it's a question so the I I found out why
you get so mad at the people on the
internet and I'm I'm going to ask you
tell me if you think this is accurate so
wait wait you have a hypothesis you just
said I found out why as if exactly
hypothesis correction hypo my hypothesis
tell me what you think about this
Instagram crowd is just the Instagram
crowd and then there's varying levels of
behavior so some people are just some
people they'll just be like hey anything
Tom posts I just love it everything I
don't care I don't even know if I agree
with I never thought about that but I
love it yep Tom hell yeah like like like
love right right then there's people on
the other side no matter what no matter
what you post ah it's uh I don't know
something negative it's always going to
be negative I don't like yeah exactly
right if you truly believe like okay
there are people like this there are
people like this and everywhere in
between if I don't know them personally
it doesn't matter it's actually just
internet characters if you truly believe
that it's hard to get bothered by it
that seems my hypothesis is you've
created this in order for you not to get
annoyed with these human beings and I
like it I you like it yeah no oh that's
that's your your response to my my
hypothesis I will I will definitely do
the same thing simil oh it's a bot like
it's a bot who cares like this is just
that's how you got you really got to
look right because there's no Rhyme or
Reason in a way it is that it's not an
actual bot like a computer bot but in a
way it is you don't know each other it's
not like they're in no position to have
an opinion about you on a personal level
and you're in no position to evaluate
that opinion you don't know each other I
think one of the biggest problems that
I've always had with with everybody is
like when I see somebody have a problem
with
everybody you millions of father when I
when I see people with extreme Talent
like Talent is very common right that
don't utilize that talent that drives me
inane and but you know uh I got to
remember like you know people tell me
like listen not everybody's going to
have the same work ethic but for me it's
like how could you not have a certain
code that you live by how could you not
like want to be the best dude that you
could be how can you not see common
sense and perhaps that's a little bit of
uh narcissism on my end to think that
everybody should believe like me because
they shouldn't but it's for me it's like
all right if you're a man and you're on
the internet talking trash to somebody
you don't know you're definitely not at
a high level in your life in any aspect
and don't you want to be don't you want
to be you know uh if you're a kid with
talent and you you're not mad at them
you're just disappointed in like I
actually know them I don't know these
people you know it's like uh you know
people who run from problems people who
start problems behind a fake name there
it's hard for me to respect certain kind
of individuals you know I was talking my
students about this the other day two of
my students went through the same exact
thing same exact thing they messed up
heavily they messed up big time and they
got torn into and one of the students
ran because they didn't want to face
their problems and the other student
raised up and became better which one
are you going to be you know it's very
easy to run run but if you keep running
from all your problems eventually you're
going to find you're going to be very
lonely in a box with nothing around you
because life is about making mistakes
you're going to fail and you're going to
succeed you're going to fail you're
going to get knocked down are you going
to get up or what are you going to do
you're going to run you know what I mean
so it's hard for me to respect people
who constantly never want to admit their
faults never want to admit that they're
wrong and just and I don't like people
who don't like
me makes s you're a good man the good
work appreciate you Tom any uh any
closing thoughts bro I I really
appreciate you guys for having me on
here thank you I love all that you do
means a lot to me and I said for a while
uh Joo is the real deal not that he
needs anyone to tell him that but I
don't respect I respect everyone but I
don't I don't know the proper word uh
admire many people definitely admire you
man it's it's very hard to live like you
live uh it's very hard hard to keep up
the discipline that you keep up and uh
you know I hope everybody understands
that listen I I I I make mistakes I know
that love me or hate me just know my
intentions are they're pure so if I
could ever help you in any way I hope I
I hope I do all right so thank you
everybody for tuning in check out my
sponsor Pitbull uh USA great people
check out my school uh listen to the
Jaco podcast bye the The Malt Shake is
quite delicious to be quite honest I'm
not I could drink this just as a snack
oh believe me you're not the only one in
this room that drinks that as a snack
right there incredible a good snack to
have indeed man well thanks for joining
us uh I I'm sorry it took a while to get
make all this happen but actually it's
it's taken a lot longer for some other
people so I'm glad we finally got it set
up and thanks for thanks for sharing
what you've been through your
experiences on and off the mat the
lessons that you've learned and and
really what you're doing right now you
don't want to talk about making an
impact like I said you've already made
an impact on one kid you've change a
trajectory of their life and you're
going to do that over and over again I
know there's many more on the list
already so thanks for what you're doing
to help kids of all ages and I mean of
all ages that's two to two to to 82 um
help them overcome what they're facing
getting bullied getting abused you're
making a difference and um we're
grateful so thank you thank you guys
appreciate
you and with that Tom de Blast has left
the building for now we're about to go
do a seminar with Tom last here in a
little bit so that's awesome
obviously jiujitsu man what a huge piece
of his life but you know that that story
that he told about the kid that got
picked on and I you know I follow Tom on
Instagram so I kind of see this stuff as
happening but I didn't know the followup
like the kid that dressed up like
Spider-Man and got made fun of and all
this stuff he's doing his first
jiu-jitsu tournament yeah you and I both
know what it takes to do a jiu-jitsu
tournament yeah like if you're a
15-year-old or a 13-year-old or a
10-year-old or a 48-year-old and you're
going to do a jiu-jitsu
tournament that is such a huge step in
your life yep it's gonna you're GNA
overcome so much you're going to it's
just going to be a life-changing
experience yeah it's going to make you
so much better and here's a kid that was
not on that path that's now on that
jiujitsu path it's true like you to do
to decide to do a tournament is like you
have to kind of embrace Jiu-Jitsu in a
way that you know that it's going to
take some some mental strength I'm not
saying is it the hardest thing in the
world no but I'm just saying like
there's a difference between someone
saying oh yeah I'll just do a Jiu-Jitsu
class and that's sort of it versus
someone who's like Embraces juu and be
like no I want to go into a competition
there two different things implied thing
that I didn't say is like this is a
person that's been bullied yep that that
may that's what I should like for a
person look for a normal person to go do
a a jistic tournament is a a step up
it's out their comfort zone it's like
they're they're face to face with
someone they're going to win or lose in
front of people like there's a lot going
on there but now you have someone that's
been
bullied and they're made that whole
transition yep they made that whole
transition and now they're going to
compete like this is a life-changing
thing oh yeah yeah that's true huh cuz
you know on one hand or at one point
it's like I'm I'm being kind of the
receiving end of this you know this this
hostility and all this stuff in a in a
really a position of
inferiority and on the receiving end and
then yeah to make the transition all the
way down to the the fact I'm choosing
now to go compete yeah now I'm superior
now oh actually no I have to basically
put my myself on the stage to prove
whether or not I'm superior you know the
spirit of competition of course but just
to have that mindset now bro that's a
that's a full 180 right there full 180
speaking of 180s DEA
reset so we got this thing we did it
last year it's like the New Year's type
thing hey it's a New Year's and you know
I've always said like hey dude don't
wait till New Year's like start now but
we did this thing last year it was kind
of low profile um so it's basically like
here's the things that you're going to
do you're going to do 100 burpees at or
100 burpees or 10 minutes worth you're
going to eat clean you're going to make
a list of which is we you're going to
follow a protocol right you're going to
get on the path yeah going to kind of
mandate that you're going to get on the
path discipline equals Freedom
reset that's we and so we did it last
year I kind of you know cool I was like
stoked but this is kind it's kind of how
I this is sort of a normal life for me
yeah but it had such a huge impact on so
many people when we did it last year
like people made life changes like these
kind of Life Changes yeah and so this
year we are going like trying to get
trying to get it out there um we also
got we made it better so we got we Jason
kipa he laid out a bunch of uh workouts
yeah so we got like health and fitness
daily workouts from Jason kipa we got
leadership stuff coming from Echelon
front we got discipline directives
coming from me we got you know it's
obviously fueled by Joo fuel but it's
coming there's I'm going to do a warning
order so the military warning order is
like here's the mission here's what
you're gonna be doing here's what you
need to prepare yeah so I got that
coming and let people know about that de
reset where we are going to get the
world on the path on the path that's
what we're doing so stand by for some of
that uh joof fuel joof fuel.com check
out joof fuel.com to get some good clean
stuff in your life to put in your body
that's what we're doing we're making the
cleanest and best possible supplements
that we can make we got everything
from some a a beverage that you can
drink that will give you energy y now
look some people call that an energy
drink but I don't want you to think of
something with 400 migs of caffeine I
don't want you to think of something
with sucros and other artificial
sweeteners that are bad for you I don't
want you to think of something with a
bunch of chemical preservatives that are
bad for you I don't want you think about
any of that cuz none of that's in there
it's good clean
energy MK you just heard you just heard
Tom talking about that MK he's like
maybe I'll have this as a dessert
exactly yes you will I'm about to have
one for dessert so jco fuel
hydration greens get the greens and you
know what else get the creatine oh yeah
just get get just get on the Crea
train right the cre train get on the cre
train daily get your daily dose of
creatine it'll help it's going to he's
going to do all that for you so joof
fuel.com check it out also you can get
it in stores you know get WWA vitamin
shop GNC military commissaries Apes
Haner Dash stor wake Fern shopright HB
and Tas is getting it on Meyer up in the
midwest is getting it on Harris Teeter
Lifetime Fitness Shields and look if you
belong to a
gym tell your gym owner that you want to
have a Joo fuel there so you can take
what you got from the gym and enhance it
with your fuel have them email JFS sales
joof fuel.com there you go that's what
we're doing um also we got origin USA we
make stuff in America look apparently
we're training Jiu-Jitsu yes highly
recommend it's beyond highly recommended
What's Next Step Beyond highly
recommended um mandated demanded Dem
mandated man mandated look I don't
believe in mandates yeah I don't believe
in imposing my way on your way what
about insisting respectfully insisting
here's the thing in the Navy there's a
whole like hierarchy of words yeah and
one of that the the if someone's
recommending like let's say you put in
for an officer package and I think
you're okay I would write like I
recommend Eko for this program that
means don't don't take him would
recommend yeah and then it's like the
next one up is I strongly recommend and
people are still you know he's an okay
and then it's like I give the strongest
recommendation and the highest thing
that I knew of was I give my strongest
possible personal
recommendation sweet so I'm going to
give my strongest possible personal
recommendation that you start training
Jiu-Jitsu out there people understand
and when you start training Jiu-Jitsu
you're going to need a rashu guard
you're going to need a ghe so go to
origin usa.com and get yourself your G2
stuff that's made in America that's what
we're doing we're making in America it's
not made in a sweat shop by slave labor
it's not made by a 12-year-old that's
making a dollar a week to breathe in
chemicals and the chemicals that they
don't breathe in and ingest themselves
are getting dumped into the ocean that's
not what we're doing made in America
origin
usa.com get your gear there hunt gear
Delta jeans boots t-shirts joggers
joggers I didn't really understand the
jogger thing that's a thing though okay
all right yeah people be wearing their
joggers they do we we make some like I
don't know what to call them sweatpants
yeah is there a difference between
sweatpants and joggers yeah what's the
difference the fit the cut the cut of
sweatpants is baggier bager y more
tradition more traditional cut you know
joggers is like we have something that's
more toward sweatpants feel more a
little bit more like Rocky bboa to be
honest with you yeah yeah yeah I could
see that Rocky bboa is we also have
joggers so for the joggers out there uh
origin usa.com get what you need there
it's true also Joo store discipline
equals Freedom shirts we represented on
this path that we're all on or about to
get back on whatever your past scenario
may be you want to represent just go to
Joost stor.com choose what you want boom
get something also what's available on
Joo store if you don't know it's called
the shirt Locker new design shirts t-t
Shirts new design every month people
seem to like them they're a little bit
more uh outside the I paint outside the
lines a little bit on them every once in
a while but people seem to like I'm some
new design every month like I said
subscription scenario anyway it's on Joo
store it's called the shirt Locker sign
up for that if you want check it out
that's what it's called check it out
true uh if you need some steak to go
with your M which you probably do go to
Primal beef.com or go to colorcraft
beef.com get yourself some good steaks
from some some good people that's what
we're doing check them out also
subscribe to the
podcast check out Joo unraveling check
out the grounded podcast check out Jo
underground.com I just said grounded
podcast we haven't done that in like
five years I think that one's the on
Hiatus it's on a long Hiatus we'll have
to watch out for that one uh Jack
underground.com we did just cut one of
those what was that yesterday yeah or
day before just came out so check that
out as well it's $8 cents a month if you
can afford if you can't afford it's no
big deal email assistance atj
underground.com so we can bring you into
the underground world where we have
control just watch out uh YouTube check
out our YouTube check out psychological
warfare flips side canvas check out a
bunch of books obviously how you bear it
by Tom de blast and then I've written a
bunch of books so check those out as
well including the kids book way of the
warrior kid get some kids around get the
kid in your neighborhood on the path
that's another thing like that kid
training jit for the first time and
going to compete that's a lifechanger
I've had countless people tell me that
the warrior kid books change the
trajectory of a kid's
life so get those books for your kids
also ashon front we have a leadership
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership go to eamf front.com for
details we also have an online training
platform to learn about life to learn
about life leader ERS ship in life
that's what life is you lead yourself
you lead your team you lead your family
you lead your friends life is
leadership and it is a skill that you
can learn just like Jiu-Jitsu is a skill
that you can learn and just like you
have a huge advantage and almost
unmatchable advantage on the mats if you
know Jiu-Jitsu and someone else doesn't
it's the same thing when you have skills
life skills leadership skills go to
extreme ownership. comom train and study
study so you are prepared for the mats
of
life that's what I'm asking yeah also if
you want to help service members active
and retired go check out Mark Le's mom
mama Lee she got a charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to Americas Mighty
warriors.org don't forget about mic aink
he's got Heroes and horses. org Jimmy
May has got beyond the brotherhood. org
and of course you heard about it today
Tom de Blast has Buddies over bullies.
org check that out and let's help kids
get on a path in life that is going to
help them for eternity that's what we're
doing if you want to connect with us on
the interwebs Tom is there oceancounty
BJJ dcom tomthe blast.com buddies over
bullies. org he's on the gram
primarily and he will engage so just
stand by that's at Tom to blast and then
Echo is that Echo Charles I am at Jo Joo
willink just just be careful because the
algorithm is training right now it's
like in it's in training it's learning
like it's watching you and it's learning
how it can beat you yep so you got to be
on
guard otherwise it might take you down
and choke you out you don't want that
and thanks to those of you in uniform
right now around the world these are
tenuous times and you all stand on the
front lines ready to defend freedom and
our way of life and we are thankful for
it same goes to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers
boorder of Patrol Secret Service all
First Responders thank you for defending
us and keeping us safe here at
home and everyone else out
there you're not going to have an easy
path that you're not going to get it
that is the nature of the world and
that's the nature of life you will
suffer you will fall short you will make
mistakes but if you get back up if you a
regroup re-calibrate and
re-engage if you keep fighting in the
end if you bear failures and defeat with
courage and tenacity in the end you will
win so get back
up dust
off and go get after
it and until next time this is Ekko and
Joo
out